Herzlich Willkommen zur Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 24. Wir haben heute einen ganz besonderen Gast bzw. sind wir zu Gast. Und zwar bei Herrn Doktor Mathias Döpfner, dem Vorstandsvorsitzenden der Axel-Springer AG. Schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag, freu mich.
Ja, Alternativlos hat ja irgendwie immer den Anspruch zu versuchen, Dinge etwas tiefer zu beleuchten und auch ein bisschen mehr Zeit zu haben, um Sachen auszuwalzen und Gelegenheit zu geben, auch tatsächlich Verständnis zu schaffen. Und eines der Dinge, wo wir feststellen, dass gerade unsere Hörer so ein bisschen unsicher sind, ist, was macht denn eigentlich so ein Verleger? Also welches Selbstverständnis hat so ein Verlag und was ist sozusagen der Anspruch, den sie da haben?
Ich glaube, es ist wichtig, dass man eine gesellschaftspolitische Bedeutung und eine ökonomische Bedeutung in einer guten Balance hält. Verlage, die sich sozusagen nur gesellschaftspolitisch definieren, neigen sehr schnell dazu, Politik zu machen. Und das ist ungesund. Verlage, die sich rein ökonomisch definieren, neigen dazu, Journalismus und Inhalte hintanzustellen und sozusagen nur der Profitmaximierung zu dienen. Und das ist genauso falsch und führt zu schlechtem Journalismus. Also unser Selbstverständnis ist, unser Geschäft ist Inhalte, Journalismus, gute, gut recherchierte, unabhängige Geschichten, die starke, glaubwürdige Medienmarken etablieren, die Leserinnen und Lesern auf verschiedenen Vertriebskanälen, das heißt als Zeitung, als Zeitschrift, uns als Websites und als Apps auf Smartphones und Tablets Nachrichten, Meinungen und Unterhaltungsangebote machen und damit natürlich eine wichtige Rolle spielen im gesellschaftlichen Diskurs. Nur wenn Menschen Themen haben, an denen sie sich reiben können, Fakten haben, auf die sie sich beziehen können, Informationen haben, über die sie sprechen können und natürlich auch sich mit Positionen konfrontieren, die vielleicht nicht irre sind, die sie anders sehen, nur dann wird eigentlich ein gesellschaftlicher Diskurs lebendig und dazu versuchen wir beizutragen.
Das heißt, Sie sind da eher sozusagen als Enabler, also in dem Sinne nicht selbst Einfluss zu nehmen, aber das Spielfeld dafür zu schaffen, dass andere Einfluss nehmen können?
Ich glaube, wenn man als Journalist Politik machen will, ist es genauso schlecht, wie wenn man als Verantwortlicher eines Verlages versucht, Meinungen vorzugeben, also sozusagen eine zentralistisch organisierte Meinungsmaschine oder Richtungsvorgabe, die funktioniert nicht. Man muss sich entscheiden, will man gute Journalisten oder will man gehorsame Journalisten? Beides geht nicht. Gute Journalisten sind ungehorsam. Und deswegen ist das Wichtigste, dass man eine Kultur etabliert, in der es diese maximale innere Meinungsfreiheit gibt. Das heißt, ein Chefredakteursprinzip. Der Chefredakteur definiert, was in seiner Zeitung steht. Und das wiederum setzt sich in der Regel zusammen aus den Summen der unterschiedlichen Meinungen der Redakteurinnen und Redakteure. Das heißt aber nicht Beliebigkeit. Und auch da ist wieder eine Balance zu finden. Freiheit, innere Freiheit, Meinungsfreiheit, Pluralismus. Ganz wichtig. Auf der anderen Seite muss es aber auch so was geben wie einen Werte-Rahmen, in dem man sich bewegt. Und das hat ja der Axel-Springer-Verlag in einer Weise getan, die ich eigentlich sehr vorbildlich finde, weil wir unsere Werte, die gesellschaftspolitischen Grundprinzipien veröffentlichen, ganz transparent. Gibt diese fünf Präambeln, die wir im Geschäftsbericht veröffentlichen, die bei jeder anderen Gelegenheit öffentlich gemacht werden und die genau definieren, was sozusagen diese gesellschaftspolitischen Grundwerte sind, denen sich Axel-Springer verpflichtet fühlt. Das ist die deutsche und die europäische Einheit. Das ist die Unterstützung der Lebensrechte des Staates Israels und die Aushöhnung zwischen Deutschen und Juden. Das ist die Unterstützung des transatlantischen Bündnisses und die Solidarität in der freiheitlichen Wertegemeinschaft mit den Vereinigten Staaten. Das ist die Unterstützung der sozialen und freien Marktwirtschaft. Und es ist die Bekämpfung jeglicher Art von politischem Extremismus. Das sind die fünf Prinzipien. Sie sehen daran, das ist keine Parteipolitik, keine Personalpolitik. Es ist überhaupt keine Tagespolitik. Es sind gesellschaftliche, gesellschaftspolitische Grundwerte. Und das sagen wir. Dafür stehen wir. Aber in diesem Rahmen ist natürlich ganz viel oder fast alles möglich. Denn wer grundsätzlich Amerika, das transatlantische Bündnis unterstützt, kann trotzdem die aktuelle Regierung in Amerika oder in Israel kritisieren. Und wer für Europa ist, der kann auch Eurobonds kritisieren. Also das Spektrum der Meinungen bleibt groß und muss groß bleiben und ist niemals zentral gesteuert.
Würden Sie sagen, dass das gelingt, dass die Redakteure auch also frei kritisieren dürfen? Oder ist es eher so, dass sich so Alar Chomsky, quasi der, der in den Platz kommt in der Zeitung, schon so weit sozialisiert ist innerhalb ihres Wertekanons, dass er das nicht tun würde?
Also ich will versuchen, jetzt eine differenzierte Antwort darauf zu geben. Natürlich ist diese Veröffentlichung der Werte, die ich gerade zitiert habe, schon so eine Orientierung, bei der jemand, der jetzt fundamental anti-amerikanisch ist, also der amerikanische, kapitalistische, imperialistische Vorstoß ist sozusagen das Elend der Welt. Und je schneller dieses System in sich zusammenstürzt, desto besser für den Rest der Welt. Wer so eine Position hat, der wird sich vermutlich gar nicht angezogen fühlen von unserem Haus. Und wenn er in diesem Sinne, also sozusagen fundamental anti-amerikanisch argumentieren würde, dann würde es glaube ich schon eine Diskussion geben, wo wir sagen, also das ist eigentlich nicht das, was wir mit dieser Präambel gemeint haben. Auf der anderen Seite, seit ich hier im Haus bin und das jetzt schon über 10, 12 Jahre, ist das noch kein einziges Mal passiert. Und in dem Sinne muss ich schon sagen, dass ich eigentlich vom ersten Tag an hier auch wirklich daran gearbeitet habe, dass dieses Prinzip des Ungehorsams, des Widerspruchgeistes, der Unberechenbarkeit der Zeitung wirklich in der Praxis gelebt wird. Ich habe das selbst so erlebt. Ich bin so journalistisch sozialisiert worden bei der FAZ, wo ich als Musikkritiker anfing und Anfang der 80er Jahre und eben in solchen Auseinandersetzungen über meine Meinung, die damals vielleicht nicht zur Blattlinie passten, erlebt habe, wie wichtig es für einen Journalisten ist, wenn man dann sagt, okay, we disagree, wir finden das völlig falsch, aber wir drucken es trotzdem. Und das ist genau die Kultur, die ich auch hier im Hause befördere. Und jetzt bin ich nicht naiv genug zu glauben, dass es hier eine perfekte Welt wäre und alles super läuft, mit Sicherheit nicht. Aber eines sage ich mittlerweile auch mit allem Selbstbewusstsein, das vielleicht nicht ins Klischee passt. Ich habe schon in mehreren Verlagen gearbeitet und beobachte, wie in anderen Häusern gearbeitet würden, höhere von Journalisten, was sie in anderen Häusern erleben. Ich glaube, dass Axel-Springer im Moment in Deutschland, der vielleicht liberalste, freiheitlichste Verlag ist und wo wirklich die Journalisten das Gefühl haben, dass sie schreiben können, was sie für richtig halten. Da sie es mir vermutlich nicht glauben, empfehle ich, mit dem einen oder anderen zu sprechen, den sie für einen Widerspruchsgeist halten und sagen, wie ist denn das wirklich dabei Springer?
Die Grundlage dafür ist natürlich, dass es ein wirtschaftlich solides Verlag ist, dass die Ökonomie stimmt und man genug Geld reinbekommt, um das Ganze im Laufen zu halten. Nun jammern die Verlage ja schon seit vielen Jahren so, dass es halt irgendwie schlecht ist und die Auflagenzahlen sinken und das Internet sie alle fressen wird und Google am Horizont droht oder schon der große Gegner ist. Wie schlimm ist es denn tatsächlich? Also was sind denn eigentlich die Probleme, die da heute tatsächlich da sind?
Vielleicht zwei Bemerkungen dazu. Zum einen, also wir sind glücklicherweise wirtschaftlich hoch erfolgreich. Wir veröffentlichen seit sieben Jahren mit Ausnahme des Krisenjahres 2009 ein Rekordergebnis nach dem anderen, also historische Rekordergebnisse. Das Haus ist hoch profitabel. Das verdanken wir im Wesentlichen der frühen Digitalisierung. Wir haben früher als alle anderen Verlage angefangen, unser Geschäft eben nicht als das Bedrucken von Zeitungen zu verstehen, sondern als das Erstellen von Inhalten, von gutem Journalismus und zwar auf allen Kanälen und eben vor allen Dingen im Internet. Und das trägt mittlerweile schon 33 Prozent unseres Gesamtumsatzes bei und 34 Prozent des Gesamtgewinns. Das heißt, deshalb wegen dieser Digitalisierung geht es uns wirtschaftlich außerordentlich gut. Zweite Bemerkung. Ich glaube, dass es auch gut ist, wenn es Verlagen gut geht und wenn Journalismus ein Geschäftsmodell ist. Man kann natürlich sagen, das hört sich so kapitalistisch und irgendwie kalt an, ist doch schöner, wenn Journalismus nur etwas Idealistisches ist. Ich glaube das überhaupt nicht, weil das führt dazu, dass es erstens weniger Angebot gibt. Denn da, wo kein Geschäftsmodell ist, wird es auch schwierig, mit großen Ressourcen und vielen Arbeitsplätzen unabhängig zu recherchieren. Und zweitens ist natürlich der Journalist, der nur einer guten oder vermeintlich guten Sache dient, ganz schnell auch so etwas wie Aktivist und sind die Verleger, die nicht mehr sagen, wir wollen Gewinnerwirtschaften, sondern wir tun das, um die Welt zu beglücken, ganz schnell im Grenzbereich zum Politiker, zum Weltverbesserer, zum Ideologen, der möglicherweise eine langfristig unerfreuliche Agenda hat. Wenn man mal guckt in die Geschichte, dann war das in der Tat auch noch vor gar nicht so langer Zeit vielfach so. Also im 19. Jahrhundert und im 18. Jahrhundert waren viele Verlage sozusagen Besitztümer reicher Leute, die gesagt haben, ich habe eine bestimmte Meinung, ich will die Zentrumspartei unterstützen und durchsetzen. Und deswegen habe ich gründlich einen Verlag, deswegen für öffentliche Zeitungen, also Zeitungen sozusagen als Propagandainstrument. Und das, glaube ich, funktioniert heute Gott sei Dank nicht mehr. Es funktioniert vor allen Dingen auch in der digitalen Welt nicht mehr so leicht. Und deshalb, glaube ich, ist es ganz gesund, wenn es eben neben diesem inhaltlichen Wollen auch das ökonomische Müssen gibt, weil das Verlage zu einem Pragmatismus zwingt und ihnen sozusagen diese ideologische, politische Weltverbessererdimension nimmt. Also ich glaube, es gibt im gesamtgesellschaftlichen Interesse durchaus viele gute Gründe dafür, dass Journalismus ein erfolgreiches Geschäftsmodell ist und bleibt.
Aber dabei ist natürlich die Frage, gerade große Konzerne, die einen großen Teil des Anzeigen Volumens beisteuern, können natürlich relativ problemlos dann auch Einfluss nehmen auf die Redaktion, direkt oder indirekt. Also die wirtschaftliche Situation der Zeitung, die prekärer sie wird, desto problematischer ist natürlich einfach der Einfluss der Anzeigenkunden.
Sie sprechen ein absolutes Lieblingsthema von mir an, weil genauso wie sie es beschreiben, ist es. Je mehr ein Verlag von wenigen Anzeigenkunden abhängt und je ungesunder er insgesamt ökonomisch ist, desto höher ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass diese wenigen Anzeigenkunden Einfluss auf die Berichterstattung nehmen. Man muss leider sagen, dass das an der einen oder anderen Stelle heute schon der Fall ist. Die Versuche werden immer wieder gemacht, tausche ein paar Anzeigen gegen nette Berichterstattung. Das ist das Ende von glaubwürdigem, unabhängigem Journalismus. Deshalb ist es so wichtig, dass Verlage wirtschaftlich erfolgreich sind und unabhängig sind. Übrigens auch deshalb ist es so wichtig, dass sie nicht nur auf Anzeigeneinnahmen angewiesen sind, sondern dass sie auch vor allen Dingen als 2. große Erlösquelle den zahlenden Leser haben, der mit dem Geld, das ihm diese Art von Journalismus wert ist, dazu beiträgt, dass Anzeigen nur ein Teil der Einnahmen sind und dass es sich dann ein Verlag eben leisten kann, gegenüber einem Anzeigenkunden völlig unabhängig aufzutreten und zu sagen, das machen wir nicht. Ich kann Ihnen sagen, in unserem Haus spielt das eine sehr große Rolle. Wir haben sehr früh schon im Jahr 2003 eingeführt Leitlinien zur Sicherung der journalistischen Unabhängigkeit. Da haben wir es unseren Journalisten regelrecht verboten, mit Anzeigenkunden Gespräche über irgendwelche Berichte zu führen und ganz harte Grenzen gezogen und gesagt, sobald ein Journalist von einem Anzeigenkunden sich einladen lässt oder irgendwelche Geschenke annimmt oder irgendwelche Absprachen trifft, ist das ein harter Verstoß gegen unsere Leitlinien. Wir haben übrigens auch schon die eine oder andere konkrete Erfahrung gemacht. Ich will jetzt keine konkreten Namen nennen, aber wo große Anzeigenkunden uns gesagt haben, wir haben uns so über ihre Berichterstattung geärgert, wenn sie das nicht abstellen, kündigen wir sämtliche Anzeigen bei ihnen. Dann haben wir gesagt, gut, dann müssen sie das tun, haben weiter berichtet. Dann haben die tatsächlich alle Anzeigen gekündigt. Und dann haben wir einfach weitergemacht. Nicht aggressiver als vorher, nicht milder als vorher, einfach weitergemacht. Und nach ein paar Monaten kamen sie wieder zurück, weil sie nämlich gemerkt haben, dass sie einen Fehler gemacht haben. Also ich glaube, ein selbstbewusster Verlag, der sich von solchen Druck- und Drohversuchen nicht einschüchtern lässt, schützt am Ende sein Geschäftsmodell. Und das Geschäftsmodell basiert auf unabhängigem, unberechenbaren Journalismus, der auf die Wünsche von Anzeigenkunden keine Rücksicht nimmt.
Wie ist denn momentan das Verhältnis? Also wie viel Prozent der Einnahmen kommen denn noch aus Anzeigen? Und wie viel aus Beteiligung direkt in Einnahmen?
Bei uns ziemlich genau 50-50. Die Hälfte der Einnahmen kommt aus dem Anzeigengeschäft, die andere Hälfte kommt aus dem Vertrieb. Also das heißt vom Abonnenten oder vom zahlenden Käufer, der am Kiosk oder für eine App eben etwas bezahlt.
Und wie ist das im Rest des deutschen Verlags wesens?
Etwas stärker zugunsten der Anzeigenerlöser. Also wir haben einen relativ ungewöhnlich hohen Vertriebserlösanteil. Aber die deutschen Verlage sind da wiederum generell auch stärker noch von Vertriebserlösen abhängig oder stärker auch durch Vertriebserlöse unabhängig gemacht, so muss man es ja eigentlich sagen, als dass beispielsweise viele Verlage in Amerika sind, wo teilweise die Anzeigenerlöse bis zu 80 Prozent betragen.
Wie würden Sie denn sagen, also wenn Sie uns erzählen, dass Sie harte Regeln vergeben haben gegen Reden mit Anzeigenkunden, das klingt ja so, als wenn es ein konkretes Problem gegeben hätte, oder als wenn es mehr als einfach proaktiv, wir müssen da jetzt mal ein Riegel verschieben, sondern wie hoch würden Sie denn sagen, ist die Quote insgesamt im Verlagswesen von Einflussnahme? Womit ich meine, ich meine jetzt auch so Sachen wie vorgefertigte Berichte, PR-Texte und so weiter.
Also erstmal muss ich natürlich sagen, da gibt es noch einen Unterschied zwischen Zeitschriften und Zeitungen. Bei Zeitschriften ist es viel stärker als bei Zeitungen und wiederum bei einigen Zeitschriftensegmenten, also insbesondere Mode-Zeitschriften, da sind die Sitten, muss man ehrlich sagen, komplett verdorben. Also da geht es wirklich teilweise so, wir schalten hier nur eine Anzeige, wenn es ein schönes Porträt gibt und im Übrigen, wenn im Bericht das Produkt so und so vorkommt. Das ist offen gestanden das Gegenteil von Journalismus, das ist gekauftes Marketing und das muss jeder selber sehen, ob er sowas zulässt oder nicht. Wir sind sehr früh dazu gekommen, diese Leitlinien einzuführen, nicht weil es bei uns jetzt ein besonderes Problem gab, sondern weil ich in der gesamten Branche gesehen habe, dass der Druck immer größer wird. Und weil ich gesehen habe, dass manche auch, weil sie wirtschaftlich in Schwierigkeiten sind, immer mehr geneigt sind, dem nachzugeben und sagen, so ist das halt. Und ich meine mal so ein PR-Text abdruckender, davon geht die Welt auch nicht unter. Und deswegen haben wir gedacht, jetzt ziehen wir hier einen Riegel ein. Das ist damals ziemlich belächelt worden, auch bei uns im Unternehmen ein bisschen so, dass jetzt der Moraltrip vom Vorstandsvorsitzenden, glaubt er jetzt nur, weil wir mal ein gutes Jahresergebnis haben, dass er sich das leisten kann und so. Und ich habe immer gesagt, es geht nicht um Moraltrip. Es geht erstens mal um eine Frage des Grundanstands und sozusagen eine Grundlage von unabhängigem Journalismus. Und es geht aber auch um den Schutz unseres Geschäftsmodells. Weil wenn ein Anzeigenkunde lernt, dass er mit einer kleinen Incentive-Reise wohlmeinende Berichterstattung billiger erkaufen kann als mit einer Anzeige, dann wird er lieber Redakteure bestechen, als Anzeigen zu schalten. Und das ist neben der moralischen Dimension auch einfach schlecht für unser Geschäft. Also aus diesen beiden Gründen habe ich damals gesagt, wir machen das. Es ist belächelt worden. Dann sind die ersten Schleichwerbungsskandale öffentlich geworden. Das war damals im Fernsehen. Ich glaube Sat1 und ARD waren zwei große Sachen. Und da war dann so ein bisschen so, ach, war vielleicht doch ganz gut, dass wir es gemacht haben. Und wir haben jetzt gerade vor kurzem noch mal eine Diskussion geführt und ein paar Dinge verschärft. Verschärft noch gegenüber den Regeln, die wir 2003 eingeführt haben und das jetzt in unseren neuen Code of Conduct eingeführt. Ich halte es wirklich, ich bin da sehr rigoros, weil ich einfach glaube, dass es echt wichtig ist, dass wir an der Stelle keine falschen Kompromisse machen.
Wenn man sich ihre Digitalstrategie ansieht, wir haben jetzt geredet von Apps und von überhaupt die ganzen Einnahmequellen, dann sieht man beim Axel-Springer-Verlag eine Sache, die ich interessant finde, nämlich, dass sie nicht eine Axel-Springer-App haben, sondern sie haben eine App pro Zeitung sozusagen, die das machen will. Und auch die Strategien der einzelnen Zeitungen sind alles andere als identisch. Sie haben da durchaus Spielraum in den einzelnen Redaktionen. Ist das Absicht oder warten Sie, ist das so eine Art, wir gucken mal, wer gewinnt, und das machen wir dann hausweit, oder ist das?
Das ist Absicht. Und zwar sowohl inhaltlich journalistisch als auch strategisch, wenn es jetzt um die Digitalisierung geht. Also inhaltlich ist dieser Pluralismus genau wichtig aus den Gründen, die wir ganz am Anfang besprochen haben. Und das sehen Sie bei uns immer wieder. Also die Welt sagt, der Türkei-Beitritt in die EU ist falsch. Die BILD-Zeitung sagt, der Türkei-Beitritt in die EU ist richtig und muss so schnell wie möglich passieren. Die BILD-Zeitung hat vorletzten US-Präsidentschaftswahlkampf den einen Kandidaten gepusht, die BILD am Sonntag genau den anderen. Und die Welt hat ein Pro und Contra gemacht. Und die Welt am Sonntag hat gesagt, wir halten uns da ganz raus. Wir sollten überhaupt nichts dazu sagen, wer der bessere Präsident ist. Da sehen Sie einen wunderbarerweise Pluralismus, der sich einfach so ergibt. Und genauso wie wir es mit dem Journalistischen machen, so machen wir es eben auch strategisch, wenn es jetzt darum geht, neue Geschäfte, die sich entwickeln oder neue Vertriebskanäle, die sich entwickeln, zu erschließen. Wir wissen es doch nicht, wie es wirklich läuft. Wir wissen nicht, was ist die beste App. Also nehmen Sie mal das Beispiel App. Die BILD und die Welt haben eine App gemacht. Die BILD hat eine hochgradig sophisticated App gemacht, sehr verspielt übrigens auch auf einer Spiele-Programmierung, sogar basierenden Technologie. Und die Welt hat eine ganz einfache, sehr stark fast einer traditionellen Zeitungsoptik angelehnte App gemacht. Völlig unterschiedliche Konzepte, esthetisch und inhaltlich. Und es war interessant zu sehen, dass plötzlich an der Stelle sogar der Weltansatz, anders als wir es vermutet hätten, besser funktioniert hat. Und genauso machen wir es auch, wenn es jetzt darum geht, Bezahlmodelle auszuprobieren, Technologien auszuprobieren. Da wir nicht wissen, was richtig ist, ist es doch viel klüger, parallel unterschiedliche Wege auszuprobieren. Und wenn man dann merkt, das eine funktioniert gar nicht, aber das andere immer wieder, dann ist es natürlich wahrscheinlich, dass das auch intern dann kopiert wird und dass mehr sich in diese Richtung entwickeln. Aber das ist dieser, glaube ich, ganz gesunde Trial-and-Error-Prozess.
Sehen Sie denn schon, ob die Paywalls funktionieren?
Ja Moment, Paywall in dem Sinne gibt es ja noch gar nicht. Was wir ja nur gesagt haben, dass wir erstmal im ersten Schritt auf den mobilen Angeboten, das heißt auf den Tablet-Apps und auf den Smartphone-Apps grundsätzlich keine kostenlosen Angebote machen. 70% aller Apps sind kostenpflichtig. Die Funktion einer App ist für den Leser, die Leserin ein hoffentlich wichtiger Beitrag und die Bereitschaft, dann dafür auch zu bezahlen, so wie man für ein Telefongespräch bezahlt, so wie man für eine SMS bezahlt, um vielleicht zu sagen, komme fünf Minuten später, wenn wir nicht das Selbstbewusstsein haben, dass man auch für das, wofür wir von morgens bis abends arbeiten und ein paar hundert Leute in Bewegung sind und hohe Recherchekosten und Reisekosten und Layout-Kosten und andere Produktionskosten aufgewendet werden. Wenn wir nicht das Selbstbewusstsein haben, dafür auch ein bisschen Geld zu nehmen, dann sollten wir eigentlich unsere Tätigkeit einstellen. Insofern haben wir gesagt, zumindest auf den mobilen Geräten machen wir das. Im browsergetriebenen Internet, im Web, ist natürlich die ganze Sachlage ein bisschen komplizierter. Da gibt es nun mal die Gewohnheit seit 15 Jahren, dass alles kostenlos ist. Diesen Fehler haben die Verlage, haben wir Verlage selber gemacht. Keiner hat uns dazu gezwungen. Das hat damit zu tun, dass leider von vielen Verlagen auf der Welt das Internet komplett unterschätzt worden ist. Man hat gedacht, das ist so ein nettes Marketing-Tool, damit kann man vielleicht ein paar mehr Zeitungen verkaufen. Man hat dann nicht erkannt, dass die Digitalisierung von Informationen und von Inhalten eine Erdrutschartige Veränderung in der Medienlandschaft bedeutet und dass das die Lesangebote der Zukunft sind. Deswegen gibt es jetzt im Moment dieses Umdenken weltweit. Es ist wirklich ganz interessant, das zu beobachten, wie das ganz Dezentrale an verschiedensten Stellen passiert, dass man sagt, wenn immer mehr die klassische Funktion der Zeitung oder der Zeitschrift ersetzt wird durch digitale Angebote, dann müssen wir auch Wege finden, unsere Leserinnen und Leser davon zu überzeugen, dafür zu bezahlen. Und dazu ist zuallererst mal nötig, dass man wirklich attraktive Inhalte bietet und sie so aufbereitet, wie sie eben auch der User haben möchte, dass man zweitens extrem einfache Bezahlmodelle anbietet, die nicht kompliziert und langwierig sind, sondern die wirklich sehr schnell und einfach zu bedienen sind. Und dann kommt es natürlich auch noch darauf an, dass man einen rechtlichen Rahmen hat, dass man eben auch wirklich die Möglichkeiten hat, dann seine eigenen Inhalte tatsächlich auch zu vermarkten. An diesen drei Voraussetzungen wird im Moment gearbeitet. Und ich glaube, wir werden so eine schrittweise Veränderung sehen. Und wir als Verlag haben uns entschieden, auch hier verschiedene Sachen auszuprobieren von Freemium-Modellen, wo Spezialinhalte kostenpflichtig sind, über das Mietert-Model, das die New York Times jetzt ja doch sehr ermutigend und erfolgreich ausprobiert hat, bis hin zu anderen Modellen, wo man einzelne Artikel bezahlen wird. Also das heißt, sagen wir mal, eine reine News, die überall verfügbar ist. Für die wird keiner bezahlen. Aber für eine wirklich exklusiv recherchierte Geschichte mit einem investigativen Kern oder für eine Geschichte mit einem hohen Servicegehalt, mit einem wirklichen Mehrwert für den Leser, vielleicht sogar einem geldwerten Vorteil und natürlich auch für bestimmte Unterhaltungsangebote, glaube ich, ist der Nutzer dann schon bereit, auch zu bezahlen. Deswegen werden diese Sachen kostenpflichtig sein, aber ein anderer Teil des allgemeinen Nachrichtenangebots eben nicht. Und in dieser Weise werden wir in den nächsten 12, 18 Monaten, glaube ich, Versuche machen und eine ganze Menge Schritte machen, um eben dauerhaft sicherzustellen, dass unabhängiger Journalismus in der digitalen Welt ein Geschäftsmodell bleibt.
Können sie sich vorstellen, dass, also ich meine, bestehen sie darauf, dass sie selber sozusagen in Casso machen? Oder können sie sich auch sowas wie eine Kultur-Flatrate vorstellen?
Also vielleicht dazu eine differenzierte Antwort. Kultur-Flatrate eher nein, aber ich möchte auf keinen Fall das in Casso unbedingt selber machen. Also sagen wir mal eine Branchenlösung, die das in Casso die Abrechnung ermöglicht. Die wäre eigentlich viel besser als dezentrale Lösungen der Verlage. Das finde ich unbedingt erstrebenswert. Was jetzt die Kultur-Flatrate betrifft, ich weiß nicht genau, ob wir das Gleiche meinen, aber die Kultur-Flatrate, die sagt, du zahlst einmal einen festen Betrag und dann kannst du lesen und machen, was du willst, das ist glaube ich schwierig, weil sich natürlich die Inhalteanbieter im Wettbewerb befinden und auch weiter befinden müssen. Und das ist ja das, was sozusagen die ganze Verlegerbranche über Jahrhunderte wachgehalten hat und Journalisten angetrieben hat, rauszugehen und Fotografen angetrieben hat, rauszugehen und die besten Fotos zu machen. Wenn das nach sozialistischem Prinzip für alle gleich vergütet wird, egal was, wie viel gelesen wird, dann gibt es glaube ich diesen Anreiz nicht mehr.
Der Hintergrund ist ja, das ist ja der Verteilungsschlüssel im Hintergrund. Also die Frage ist, jeder zahlt gleich viel, aber im Hintergrund wird so verteilt, je nachdem, was wie attraktiv ist. Also die Frage wäre jetzt weniger, bestehen sie quasi pro Klick auf Bezahlung oder wäre so eine Flatrate schon okay?
Nein, also in dem Sinne, wie Sie es jetzt gerade definiert haben, ist auch so eine Flatrate diskutierbar. Ich sage nochmal, wir sind da wirklich nicht festgelegt. Entscheidend ist, dass sichergestellt sein muss, dass in einer Welt, in der nach meiner Einschätzung, in gar nicht so ferner Zukunft, der Großteil, der bedeutende Teil der Inhalteangebote in der digitalen Welt gelesen wird. Dass dann sichergestellt ist, dass Journalismus welcher Form auch immer, und ich sage ganz ausdrücklich gerade auch Blogs, die ja eine unglaubliche Bereicherung des Journalismus sind, dass das langfristig ein Geschäftsmodell sein kann, dass Leuten ihr Dasein finanziert. Denn nur dann werden sich viele Leute finden, die morgens dafür aufstehen. Wenn man das alles kostenlos machen muss, wird die Landschaft verarmen. Und das ist am Ende nicht im Interesse der Leser. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass die Nutzer mehr und mehr auch kapieren, dass das in ihrem Interesse ist. Und das sagen ja auch die Befragungen, die in der jüngsten Zeit veröffentlicht worden sind, dass es da durchaus eine wachsende Zahl von Leuten gibt, die sagen, ne, für bestimmte Sachen bin ich auch bereit zu bezahlen.
Eines der Dinge, die ja gerade in der Debatte sind, ist dieses sogenannte Leistungsschutzrecht, was ja durchaus auch von ihrem Hause relativ stark angetrieben wurde, weil sie gerade Blogger sagten, die große Befürchtung, die ja da besteht, ist, dass damit ja quasi ein Großteil der Blogosphere, die, sag mal, sich mit der deutschen Presslandschaft beschäftigt, austrocknet, weil sie halt einfach nicht mehr in der Lage ist, ohne Lizenzzahlungen zu zitieren oder halt irgendwie zu kommentieren.
Moment, also das sehe ich für nun gerade völlig anders. Ich glaube, dass das Leistungsschutzrecht, so wie wir es propagiert haben und so wie es jetzt nach meiner Kenntnis auch in dem Gesetzesentwurf definiert ist, sehr wohl auch für Blogger hoch attraktiv ist und Bloggern eine sichere Einkommensbasis sichert. Also wenn Sie Blogger sehen als primär Menschen, die originär Inhalte kreieren, die kluge Gedanken, kluge Beobachtungen, kluge Recherchen betreiben und veröffentlichen, dann werden Sie bei einer gewerblichen Verwendung Ihrer Inhalte, und nur darüber reden wir im Leistungsschutzrecht, also private Nutzer, die etwas kopieren, sind davon ja gar nicht betroffen. Aber gewerbliche Nutzer, die das dann verwenden, was ein Blogger schreibt, also nehmen wir mal einen Blog über Finanzprodukte oder einen Blog über Fußball, das wird natürlich von Industrieplayern genutzt, einfach mal kopiert und kostenlos weiterverteilt oder sogar teilweise vermarktet.
Na, das ist jetzt schon eine Urheberrechtsverletzung. Also da brauche ich kein Leistungsschutzrecht, um mich da vorzuschützen.
Na doch, also das Leistungsschutzrecht sichert natürlich, das sichert nicht nur das Recht des Autors, sondern das sichert eben auch, und das ist ja bei einem Blog sehr wohl auch der Fall, es sichert auch das Recht desjenigen, der Recherche finanziert, der die dafür nötigen Reisen finanziert, der eine entsprechende Darstellungsform finanziert. Und das glaube ich ist doch im Interesse aller, des kleinen Bloggers, des größeren Bloggers, es gibt ja mittlerweile auch Superblogs, wo sie gar nicht, also wo ich zumindest nicht mehr unterscheiden kann, worin unterscheidet sich ein Superblog wie politico von einer Washington Post eigentlich. Also das sind doch alles fließende Grenzen. Und ich finde es wirklich, ich finde es ganz falsch und ich sehe auch keine sachliche Basis dafür, hier sozusagen jetzt die Blogger gegen die Verlage oder die Großen gegen die Kleinen auszuspielen. Erstens ist es sehr oft so, dass aus Kleinen groß wird. Auch Axel-Springer hat mal in einem Schweinestall angefangen. Und zweitens, ja es war wirklich so, er hat im Schweinestall angefangen zu arbeiten. Und zweitens ist es doch ganz ausdrücklich so, dass hier die Rechte all derjenigen geschützt werden, die eine schützenswerte geistige Anstrengung und Leistung erbringen. Und sie sollen geschützt werden vor denen, die sie gewerblich, also zur eigenen Gewinnerwirtschaftung, weiterverbreiten. Nichts anderes als das Leistungsschutzrecht.
Also wenn ich mir zu diesem Entwurf genauer angucke, dann sehe ich halt irgendwie zum einen, dass er extrem unscharf ist. Also dass genau die Definition von gewerblich ist so dermaßen schwammig, dass es quasi unmöglich ist, zu sagen, zum Beispiel Felix Block irgendwie, ob es gewerblich ist oder nicht. Also du machst zum größten Teil Kommentare auf Presseberichte, so kurze Ausrüstung.
Also ich muss sagen, dass ich den Eindruck habe, im Moment haben wir so eine Art Utopie, die wir leben können, weil jeder Zugriff auf alle Informationen hat. Und dadurch ergibt sich überhaupt die Möglichkeit, einen Aggregator zu führen in der Mitte, der auf die linkt, die wichtig sind und damit einen Beitrag zur Meinungsbildung schafft. Aber wenn ich jetzt für meine Quellen bezahlen muss, also jetzt unabhängig vom Leistungsschutzrecht schon im Vorfeld, wenn ich jetzt eine Paywall vor jeder Quelle habe, dann werde ich mir ein paar aussuchen, von denen ich einen Vorurteil habe, dass die gut sind. Und den Rest werde ich gar nicht mehr zur Kenntnis nehmen.
Aber das will doch das Leistungsschutzrecht gar nicht. Also gerade verlinken können sie weiterhin. Und gerade Quellen können sie natürlich besonders gut verwenden, ohne in irgendeiner Weise ins Leistungsschutzrecht zu gefallen, weil das ja schon alleine unter dem Rubrum bibliografischer Hinweis ihnen absolut unbenommen ist, das zu tun. Wenn sie eine Überschrift oder ein Textelement nehmen, benutzen und die Quelle nennen, dann ist es schon alleine durch den bibliografischen Charakter außerhalb des Leistungsschutzrechts. Also ich glaube wirklich nicht, das ist vielleicht ein Missverständnis, das man auflösen muss. Ich glaube nicht, dass das Leistungsschutzrecht, so wie es jetzt im Gesetzesentwurf definiert ist, die Rechte oder die Möglichkeiten der Blogger beschneidet, sondern im Gegenteil, ich glaube, dass es Good News ist für alle Blogger, weil es ihnen eine wirtschaftliche Basis verschafft, die sie im Moment nicht hätten. Und deswegen ist es meines Erachtens für den kleinen Blogger genauso gut wie für den Großverlag. Es ist eine Grundsatzfrage, ob wir es zulassen wollen, dass hier eben auch große Player, große Aggregatoren hergehen können und in systematischer Weise Rechercheleistungen, intellektuelle Anstrengungen anderer nehmen können und sie in einem anderen Kontext vermarkten. Das finde ich ist ein Problem, weil es langfristig dazu führt, dass es nicht mehr viele geben wird, die sich diese Anstrengungen, diese unabhängige Recherche noch überhaupt leisten können. Und damit verarmt die Landschaft und das ist auch nicht gut für die Nutzer. Das soll geschützt werden.
Meinen Sie das mit Google News?
Unter anderem. Absolut. Nicht nur, aber in der Tat auch. Und es gibt ja mittlerweile auch ein paar ganz positive, auch freiwillige Beispiele, dass sich zum Beispiel das Flipboard und die New York Times eben darauf geeinigt haben, dass hier tatsächlich Gebühren bezahlt werden für die Inhalte, die verwendet werden. Das zeigt doch auch, dass da was Positives in Bewegung ist. Also ich finde wirklich diesen Kulturpessimismus sozusagen, also ich glaube, wir sind ja alle ein bisschen weiter, dass wir sagen, also nur noch eine Welt, in der alle Inhalte gratis sind, erwirkt Demokratie, Freiheit und Humanismus, dass das eine Utopie ist, die also krachend zusammenkrachen muss, laut zusammenkrachen muss, weil das ist ja nun ganz klar etwas, was nicht funktionieren kann, weil wenn für diese Dinge nicht mehr bezahlt wird, dann wird es auch irgendwann nicht mehr erstellt werden. Also brauchen wir differenzierte Lösungen. Und ich glaube einfach, dass das Leistungsschutzrecht, wir sind nicht mit allem zufrieden, was da jetzt in dem Gesetzesentwurf drin steht, das ist aber zumindest ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung. Ich glaube, er stärkt alle Urheber, er stärkt alle, die Inhalte und in das Erstellen von Inhalten investieren und ist insofern ein guter Schritt.
Also wenn man sich mal anguckt, wie die juristische Meinung gerade sich dazu entwickelt, dann haben wir eine komplette Spaltung. Zum einen gibt es die Juristen, die meistens in Verlagdiensten sind, die sagen alles super, so wie sie sagen. Und dann gibt es die kritischen Juristen, die sagen so, ne, das Problem dabei ist halt, zum einen ist die genaue Ausgestaltung, also wann gilt ein Block als kommerziell, ab wann muss für welche Inhalte gezahlt werden, also wie groß kann sozusagen ein Schnipsel sein, ohne dass ich dafür Lizenzzahlungen leisten muss. Und dass diese Ausgestaltung für wieder dem Landgericht Hamburg obliegt, wo halt am Ende einfach eine Rechtsunsicherheit über eine gewisse Zahl von Jahren entstehen wird, die dazu führen wird, dass der Diskurs fraktioniert, dass wir da hinkommen werden, dass Felix zum Beispiel im Zweifel Verlage nicht mit zitieren wird, beziehungsweise das Verlagsprodukte nicht mit zitieren wird und kommentieren wird, die das Leistungsschutzrecht durchsetzen. Und dadurch, dass eben diese eine extreme Unklarheit schon immer schon diesen Kommentar liest zu diesem Leistungsschutzrecht. So, da stellt sich heraus, offensichtlich wissen die selber nicht, was sie eigentlich wollten.
Na ja, man kann aber auch jetzt so einen Prozess überfordern, indem er sagt, es muss sozusagen jede kleine Unschärfe sofort aufgelöst werden, dann wird nie irgendein Gesetz ergehen und dann wird es nie einen Schritt geben. Ich will nur noch mal eines festhalten, weil sie es eben auch noch mal wiederholt haben. Da liegt echt ein Missverständnis vor. Felix von Leitner wird völlig unbeschränkt weiter zitieren können und benutzen können Überschriften, Texte, solange er sie entweder selbst eintippt. Deswegen ist ja zum Beispiel auch Twitter überhaupt nicht davon betroffen. Wenn ich bei Twitter irgendwas eingebe, fällt das nicht unter Leistungsschutzrecht, weil ich muss es ja selbst eintippen. Deswegen ist es egal, ob ich es mir selber ausgedacht habe oder jetzt klugen Gedanken von Herrn Rieger weiter verbreite. Wenn er es in seinem Blog macht, dann ist es dann nicht vom Leistungsschutzrecht erfasst oder wird es dann nicht angegriffen, wenn er die Quelle nennt. Das ist doch sowieso journalistisch sauber. Das machen sie doch ohnehin.
Aber stellt sich zum Beispiel die Frage, nehmen wir an, ich blende jetzt eine Werbung ein, bin ich dann gewerblich?
Ich glaube, wenn sie systematisch mit der Verwertung anderer Leute Inhalte ein Geschäft machen, dann fallen sie in diese Kategorie gewerblich. Der eigentliche Grund des Leistungsschutzrechts ist doch nicht der Blogger, der vielleicht zwei Anzeigen in seinem Kontext hat. Und deswegen hat er immer noch das Recht, den bibliografischen Hinweis vorzunehmen, so wie wir es eben gerade besprochen haben. So das Ziel ist, dass ein großer Konzern wie Siemens oder die Deutsche Bank, die systematisch etwas, was sich Journalisten im Schweiß ihres Angesichts als sozusagen Recherche und investigative Arbeit leisten können, weil es einen Verlag gibt, der dafür bezahlt, dass diese großen Konzerne das einfach verwenden und es einfach kostenlos verbreiten. Oder zweiter Fall, dass eben ein Aggregator einfach sagt, mein Geschäftsmodell basiert einfach nur auf Klauen und im anderen Kontext Vermarkten. Und das ist eine Imbalance, an der können wir kein Interesse haben. Und wenn das dann eben läuft wie bei Flipboard und der New York Times, dann ist es für mich vorbildlich und in diese Richtung meine ich, wird es sowieso laufen, wenn aber wir dauerhafte juristische Situation schaffen, in der eigentlich derjenige, der noch in die Erstellung von Inhalten investiert, der dumme ist, weil er diese Inhalte gar nicht mehr schützen kann, sondern kaum hat er sie digital scharf gestellt. Nehmen sie fünf Konkurrenten und vermarkten sie in ihrem Kontext. Dann, glaube ich, wird es eine Verarmung der inhaltlichen Landschaft geben. Und wir brauchen eine differenzierte Lösung. Und Herr Rieger, ja, wahrscheinlich haben Sie sogar recht, das Leistungsschutzrecht ist nicht das Ei des Kolumbus. Da könnte manches noch besser definiert sein und so weiter. Mag sein, finden auch wir Verlage. Wie gesagt, wir sind ja auch nicht zufrieden. Aber wir sind zumindest froh, dass es ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung ist. Und deswegen wäre es jetzt, glaube ich, falsch, da so eine Spaltung aufzumachen und zu sagen, das ist nur gut für die und für die ist es nicht gut. Das ist für alle gut, die in gute Inhalte investieren.
Konstanze Kurz hat ja eine Alpha-Z, die so eine kleine Dystopie entwickelt, wo sie schreibt, was wäre denn jetzt, wenn Google sagt, okay, uns ist es zu riskant. Und wir nehmen jetzt mal einfach mal alle deutschen Verlage aus dem Suchindex raus, weil wir nicht wollen, dass wir verklagt werden bzw. auf Lizenzen Anspruch genommen werden.
Haben sie ja in Belgien gemacht.
Wie es z.B. in Belgien passiert ist.
Wissen Sie, was das wäre? Das wäre ein ziemlich unappetitliches Powerplay. Das wäre das, was man auch den Missbrauch einer marktbeherrschenden Stellung nennen kann. Und das wäre ein interessanter Beleg dafür, dass es allerhöchste Zeit ist, durch ein Leistungsschutzrecht solche Missbräuche von Macht einzudämmen. Ich sehe das aber gar nicht so, weil ich glaube, dass auch hier die Polarisierung, Google ist der Böse. Ich sehe das nicht so. Wir Verlage, alle, die mit Inhalten sich befassen, profitieren natürlich auch sehr von Google und kriegen durch Google Traffic. Und deswegen ist das auch jetzt nicht eine Sache, Leistungsschutzrecht gegen Google, sondern es ist einfach nur die Vereinbarung fairer Spielregeln. Und ich glaube auch, Google ist langfristig besser beraten, wenn sie sich daran halten, wer glaubt, kurzfristig überoptimieren zu können, durch unfair search, in dem die eigenen Produkte bevorzugt dargestellt werden, oder durch Piraten-Geschäftsmodelle, die also lediglich auf dem Stehlen von Inhalten und Vermarkten im anderen Kontext basieren. Wer glaubt, dadurch kurzfristig Sonderpunkte zu machen, glaube ich, wird langfristig bestraft, weil irgendwann kommt dann echt ein Regulierer und sagt, das wollen wir nicht mehr. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass solche freiwilligen Vereinbarungen in einem frühen Stadium, die sich vielleicht auch ändern müssen über die Jahre, wahrscheinlich ist das, was man heute vereinbart, in fünf oder zehn Jahren überhaupt nicht mehr gültig. Aber dass das besser ist, als darauf zu warten, dass irgendwann der Regulierer mit der ganz großen Knute kommt.
Nun hat Google ihnen ja das Argument aus der Hand zu nehmen versucht, indem sie einfach keine Werbung einblenden bei Google News. Was ist denn die Reaktion darauf? Also ich meine, die Argumentation ist ja ganz klar, wir machen hier gar kein Geld, das ist ein Verlustgeschäft für uns, ein Service an die Bevölkerung. Wo wollen sie denn da dem anderen Mann in die Tasche?
Sie haben es ja gerade schon gesagt, das ist natürlich eine Reaktion, deren Taktik relativ schnell durchschaubar ist. Insofern spricht es eigentlich für sich.
Aber wenn Sie sagen, Sie möchten gerne an den Profiten, die andere Leute mit ihrer Arbeit machen, beteiligt werden, und Google sagt, wir machen aber gar keine Profite, dann ist das ja erstmal Widerspruch.
Das machen Sie dann jetzt in diesem speziellen Fall nicht, aber werden es vielleicht später machen, und andere machen es ja auch jetzt schon.
Aber das hieß ja, dass Sie auch im Moment mit dem Leistungsschutzrecht noch nicht verhindern könnten, dass Google das macht, oder? Weil Google kann sagen, das ist keine kommerzielle Nutzung, die wir hier tun.
Und eigentlich nur in biblografischer Weise.
Und dann werden die überhaupt nicht betroffen.
Wenn Sie sich an die Spielregeln des biblografischen Verweises halten, dann gilt das auch für Google, klar.
Das wäre nur, wie Google News ja gerade ist, ist es ja quasi nur ein Ausriss, der direkt auf die Verlagstablette linkt.
Wenn Sie die Spielregeln des biblografischen Verweises beherzigen und wenn Sie keine Vermarktung, keine systematische Vermarktung in diesem Kontext leisten, dann in der Tat wäre das langfristig auch vom Leistungsschutzrecht nicht betroffen. Insofern ist es doch wunderbar, wenn Google sagt, wir wollen das sowieso nicht, dann brauchen Sie doch gar nichts gegen das Leistungsschutzrecht zu haben. Dann betrifft Sie das ja nicht. Sollten Sie aber eine andere Agenda haben und das so lange aufbauen, bis eine Abhängigkeit entsteht, diese ganzen kleinen Krauter-Verlage, die Luft ausgeht und Google dann sozusagen der zentralistische Inhaltemakler ist, der dann auch das Monopol auf die Vermarktung hat, dann ist es ein anderes Spiel und das müssen wir jetzt nicht noch befördern, indem wir brav nicken. Also wir nehmen Google einfach beim Wort, so wie Sie es gerade gesagt haben, und sagen, wo ist das Problem?
Gut, also der eigentliche Feind ist dann der Schnipseldienst, der innerhalb von großen Konzernen eine Nachrichtenmappe macht.
Das ist auch einer der, ja was heißt Feind, das ist einer derjenigen, der... Wissen Sie, in der analogen Welt war das kein Problem. Es ist auch so, keiner ist hingegangen, hat sich sozusagen an Kopierer gestellt und hat irgendwie einen klugen Leitartikel 50.000 Mal kopiert. Ja, hat keiner gemacht, ging nicht, hat zu lange gedauert, war nicht wirtschaftlich, hat einfach nicht funktioniert. In der digitalen Welt ist es ein Klick, zack. Und deswegen sind natürlich durch die Digitalisierung einfach neue Herausforderungen entstanden. Und mit denen müssen wir uns befassen. Wir können nicht sagen, was irgendwann mal vor Jahrzehnten geregelt wurde, greift jetzt noch. Aber das ist ein Prozess. Und in diesem Prozess müssen wir uns Schritt für Schritt irgendwie an den besten Weg ran tasten.
Also mal gegebenenfalls, dieses Leistungsschutzrecht kommt jetzt in so einer oder ähnlichen Form durch. Wären Sie denn willens zu sagen, okay, für den Axel-Springer-Verlag, hier sind die Spielregeln für Blogger unter denen ihr ohne, also als Klarstellung und denen ihr lizenzfrei mit dem Material arbeiten könnt?
Absolut, sofort. Ganz klar.
Okay.
Also nochmal, ich möchte es nur einmal ganz klar sagen. Also ein Großteil unserer Mitarbeiter bloggt. Wir sind selber Blogger. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wo der Unterschied ist zwischen Blogger, Superblogger, Verleger. Also irgendwie zu sagen, wir sollten irgendetwas tun, was gegen die Blogger ist, wäre geradezu suizidal. Das sind unsere Freunde, unsere Partner, unsere Mitarbeiter. Und wir werden gerne dazu beitragen, dass es da klare Spielregeln gibt. Und dass wir die besonders vorbildlich einhalten. Und dass das etwas ist, was Blogger motiviert, mehr zu tun.
Dieses Leistungsschutzrecht war ja ein interessantes Beispiel dafür, was immer so gerne als Medienmacht bezeichnet wird, also als die Macht der Verleger, Politik zu beeinflussen. Nun haben wir ja gerade die Situation, dass Politik ja immer mehr darauf angewiesen ist, wie sie öffentlich dargestellt wird, weil die Dinge so komplex geworden sind, dass also die öffentliche Darstellung so viel wichtiger ist, als was im Gesetzestext steht, um sie durchzukriegen. Hat sich denn aus ihrer Sicht so das Verhältnis zwischen, so mal, Presse, Macht und Politik in den letzten Jahren verändert?
Interessante Frage. Ich glaube, es ist alles etwas dezentraler, etwas unübersichtlicher geworden. Es gibt nicht mehr so diese ganz kleinen Netzwerke, die irgendwie alles unter sich vereinbaren. Vielleicht ging das in Bonn auch besser. Ich komme ja daher, ich kenne es ein bisschen, bin da geboren. Und vielleicht geht das im großen unübersichtlichen Berlin nicht mehr so leicht. Und das ist gut. Ich glaube, dass diese Kumpanei zwischen Politik und Medien heute weniger vorhanden ist, dass sie überschätzt wird. Es gibt sicherlich noch Formen, wo einzelne Personen irgendwie zusammen ihre Spielchen machen. Aber ich glaube, dass es sich insgesamt eher entfremdet. Und ich glaube, dass diese Entfremdung gut ist.
Nun haben wir auf der Gegenrichtung allerdings die Konglomerate, wenn immer größer, immer weniger große Player beherrschen den Medienmarkt.
Ist das nicht ein Widerspruch? Das ist ein Problem. Da kann man verschiedene Betrachtungswinkel einnehmen. Sie können erst mal sagen, ganz so konzentriert ist es zumindest in Deutschland noch nicht. Es gibt immer noch 360 unabhängige Zeitungsverlage. Das ist absolut führend weltweit. Gibt es nirgendwo auf der Welt. In England gibt es noch 60. Und in Amerika auch nicht viel mehr. Also wir sind da weltweit absolut der fragmentierteste, kleinteiligste Markt mit natürlich dann auch der größtmöglichen Meinungsvielfalt und dem größtmöglichen Wettbewerb. Sie haben aber völlig recht. Das wird sich weiter konsolidieren und weiter konzentrieren. Und insofern tendenziell Vielfalt, gerade auch in der digitalen Welt, potenziell eher ausscheiden. Gegenbewegung sind genau die Blogger. Was sind denn die Blogger? Die Blogger sind alle Kleinstverleger. Ein Blogger ist ein Kleinstverleger. Und insofern sehe ich das auch wieder überhaupt nicht kulturpessimistisch. Ich glaube, wir haben die Chance, dass sich eigentlich im Internet möglicherweise sogar eine ganz neue Form von Vielfalt entwickelt. Da werden manche absolute Mikro-Blogger bleiben, weil die in so spezielles Thema, in so speziellen Blickwinkel und mit so winzigen Ressourcen ein Mann-Betrieb fahren, dass daraus nie etwas Größeres wird. Aber andere entwickeln sich eben Schritt für Schritt in Strukturen hinein, die dann auch wieder, wenn sie so wollen, Verlags-ähnlichen, Publisher-ähnlichen Charakter einnehmen. Und das kann dann absolut wieder auch Meinungsvielfalt und natürlich auch Qualität bedeuten. Also dieses Gerücht, im Internet wird der Journalismus schlechter, halte ich für den größten Schwachsinn, den ich je gehört habe. Das Umgekehrte ist der Fall. Im Internet kann der Journalismus viel besser werden, weil er eine viel größere Anbietervielfalt hat und weil er natürlich auf ganz andere Intelligenzressourcen zurückgreifen kann, nämlich auf die Intelligenz der Nutzer, die jederzeit einbezogen werden kann und weil er natürlich auch ganz anders im unbegrenzten Raum operiert. Das heißt, die Restriktion der Kürze, der Knappheit ist gar nicht gegeben. Ich kann im Internet ganz schnell einfach nur sozusagen ein Tweet setzen oder eine Headline auf einer Website. Ich kann aber eben auch mit 40.000 Zeichen den Sachverhalt der Euro-Krise analysieren. Viel besser als in jeder Zeitung, die dafür gleich eine Sonderausgabe machen müsste. Also die Tiefe, die Schnelligkeit, die Vielfalt und der Zugang zu neuen Intelligenzressourcen sind eigentlich Voraussetzungen dafür, dass der Journalismus in der digitalen Welt besser werden kann und auch besser werden wird. Ich glaube übrigens, dass er das heute schon ist. Einzige Sorge, die ich hätte, wenn das in einer endlosen Gratiskultur mündet, dann wird die Vielfalt auch im Internet irgendwann eingeschränkt werden. Und dann haben wir in der Tat die wenigen supermächtigen Player, die dann meistens auch eine Agenda haben. Entweder eine politische Agenda oder aber eine kommerzielle Agenda, weil sie von irgendeinem Großkonzern gesteuert sind. Und das ist nicht erstrebenswert. Aber insofern, ich glaube, wir sind auf einem ganz guten Weg.
Wenn wir uns jetzt in Berlin gerade das Verhältnis von Politik und Medien angucken, dann sehen wir immer wieder Versuche zu steuern und Einfluss zu nehmen, indem man zum Beispiel Zugang gibt oder Zugang verweigert. Also dass man einfach sagt, okay, diese Zeitung oder dieser Fernsehsender hat gerade über meine Ziele schlecht berichtet oder hat sich irgendwie nicht auf die Regierungslinie eingelassen, nicht irgendwie verkündet, dass Merkels Europapolitik alternativlos ist. So diese Dinge zu tun und das ist ja sozusagen ein relativ komplexes Spiel. So wie jetzt das Geben und Nehmen des Zugangs, des vorherigen Liegens, des Durchstechens von Informationen. Und was wir aber so aus der Beobachtung sehen, ist, dass ja da eine Menge Leute unterwegs sind, so PR-Berater und Ähnliches, die halt massiv versuchen, auf die Medien Einfluss zu nehmen. Und was mich da interessieren würde, ist eben, wie gut kann man da als Verleger eigentlich gegensteuern? Also wie gut ist man da eigentlich überhaupt in der Lage, diesen Einfluss zu unterbinden?
Ja, also erstmal würde mich natürlich interessieren, wie alternativlos zur alternativlosen Euro-Politik von Frau Merkel steht, aber das können Sie ja vielleicht noch zugeben. Kommen wir gleich noch zu. Zweitens teile ich Ihre Analyse. Sie haben recht. Drittens glaube ich, dass die Möglichkeiten der Journalisten, damit auch der Verlage, der Blogger größer sind, als man denkt, es geht immer ein bisschen mehr, als man glaubt. Man muss nämlich einfach nur Nein sagen. Und es steht nirgendwo geschrieben, dass ich auf irgendeinen Unsinn, den ein PR-Berater mir aufs Auge drücken will, reagieren muss oder Teile davon übernehmen muss. Das hat für mich mit beruflichem Selbstverständnis zu tun. Es hat mit Selbstbewusstsein zu tun. Und eines ist klar, da schließt sich wieder der Kreis, das Selbstbewusstsein ist höher dann, wenn ich wirtschaftlich unabhängig bin. Wenn ich nicht abhängig bin davon, dass mir dieser PR-Berater oder der Kunde, den man damit glücklich macht, auch in Zukunft noch Geld gibt. Wenn ich davon unabhängig bin, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr viel größer, dass ich dem dann auch wieder stehe und sage, ja, das ist eine interessante Anregung, aber es tut mir leid, ich kann mich dieser Darstellung nicht anschließen und schreibe das Gegenteil.
Würden Sie sagen, dass die Macht oder der Einfluss der Presse als vierte Gewalt abgenommen hat oder zugenommen hat?
Wenn Sie das mit dem Begriff Presse bezeichnen, dann hat der Einfluss dramatisch abgenommen. Wenn Sie sagen, ob der Einfluss des Journalismus abgenommen hat und damit also Journalismus in der digitalen Welt einschließen, dann glaube ich, dass er eher zunimmt.
Also eine Sache, die uns immer sehr am Herzen liegt, ist der Whistleblower-Schutz, den wir in Deutschland nicht haben, der in Amerika existiert. Wenn jemand bei einer Firma arbeitet, die, sagen wir mal, atomare Müll in die Umwelt kippt und der Verräter ist der Regierung, dann gibt es Gesetze oder der verräter ist den Medien, dann gibt es Gesetze, die ihn davor schützen, Repressalien innerhalb der Firma zu kriegen. Sowas haben wir hier nicht. Und wenn Sie jetzt, was ich ja sehr...
In Deutschland ist er zumindest durch den Informantenschutz gut geschützt. Also der Informantenschutz schützt ihn und schützt ja auch genau, schützt ja auch den Verlag vor der Verpflichtung, seine Quellen offen zu legen. Und das ist eben ganz wichtig. Und da muss man immer sagen, wenn da das Argument der Sicherheit und der staatserhaltenden Kraft gebracht wird, mit der man solche Quellen dann doch transparent machen müsste, dann kann ich nur sagen, aus den von Ihnen eben beschriebenen Gründen ist das ein absolut heiliges Gut. Der Informantenschutz ist eine ganz wichtige Voraussetzung dafür, dass ganz viel von dem an die Oberfläche kommt, dass ganz viele Leute nicht an die Oberfläche kommen lassen wollen.
Das kann ich als Blogger jetzt natürlich nicht geltend machen, wenn ich jetzt irgendwas finde, selber die Story, dann müsste ich über den Mittelsmann gehen, um von dem Informantenschutz geschützt zu sein.
Das weiß ich nicht, ich bin kein Jurist, aber das wäre ein interessanter Fall. Ich glaube, in dem Moment, wo Sie als Blogger, als Autor aktiv sind und haben einen Informanten, der Ihnen was sagt, dann gilt auch, Sie sind ja Ein-Mann-Verleger. Sie verlegen in Ihrem Blog Ihren eigenen Beitrag.
Ich kann den schützen, aber ich kann nicht mich schützen.
Sie schützen dann sich selbst. Wenn Sie der Autor sind, schützen Sie auch sich selbst. Aber bitte, müssen wir einen Juristen dazu nehmen. Aber das wäre mein Verständnis. Das muss so sein. Und wenn es nicht so ist, muss es dringend so geregelt werden. Natürlich.
Sie sprachen ja gerade genau dieses Verhältnis von staatlichen Sicherheitsbegehren und versus die Freiheit der Presse durch den Informatenschutz an. Insbesondere bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Was uns verwirrt hat, war, wie sehr die deutsche Presse, unter anderem auch BILD, aus ihrem Hause sich von diesem Sicherheitswahn haben einfangen lassen und von diesem, wir müssen unbedingt eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben, vollständig verkennend, dass eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung dazu führen wird, dass es eben quasi keinen Informatenschutz mehr gibt, weil ein Telefon hat ausrechnen, um jemanden zu enttarnen.
Jetzt bewegen wir uns in den Kern ihrer Themen und Interessen und ich glaube, da ist die Schnittmenge zumindest zu meiner persönlichen Meinung sehr groß. Also ich sehe das so wie sie. Wenn das einige Autoren in einigen Zeitungen unseres Hauses anders sehen, dann ist das ihr gutes Recht. Ich kann Ihnen sagen, dass ich mich als Leser auch sehr gewundert habe.
Aber Sie haben dann nicht die Knute rausgeholt und gesagt, hier, das wird jetzt okay. Wie ist denn das mit Informationsfreiheitsgesetzen? Wird das aus Ihrer Sicht gut genug genutzt oder muss das schärfer werden? Oder sind wir da schon zu weit gegangen und die Behörden sind jetzt überlastet mit irgendwelchen frivolen Anfragen?
Na ja, ich glaube, dass es...
An sich ist das ja ein starkes Instrument für Zeitungen, um Sachen rauszufinden. Aber es wird eigentlich, mein Eindruck zumindest, nicht genug genutzt. Na, ich weiß es nicht. Was ist denn Ihr Eindruck? Ist das ein reguläres Hilfsmittel für Sie, dass Sie zu Behörden gehen und irgendwelche Informationsfreiheitsanfragen stellen?
Doch, doch, das passiert schon. Ob es oft genug passiert und ob man damit vielleicht noch journalistisch viel kritischer und aktiver und vielleicht auch aggressiver umgehen könnte? Ganz ehrlich, ich weiß es gar nicht. Also, aber vermutlich haben Sie recht. Ja, ja.
Also, eines der Dinge, wo dieses Mittel relativ umfangreich eingesetzt wurde, war ja diese Causa-Wolf, wo halt ja noch eben genau über solche Anfragen operiert wurde. Haben Sie diesen Vorgang Wolfs auch so ein bisschen als Machtkampf verstanden?
Nee.
Also um die Rolle der Presse?
Überhaupt nicht. Also als Machtkampf gar nicht. Rolle der Presse, das vielleicht schon ein bisschen. Also was mich schon gewundert hat, dass bei uns auch mit hoher Massivität und mit wirklich ernst zu nehmenden Prozents als Lesereaktionen kamen, die sagen, sie machen uns den Bundespräsidenten kaputt. Man muss respektvoller mit diesem obersten Amt im Staate umgehen. Das finde ich schon bemerkenswert, das Verständnis von Journalismus. Ich dachte, es geht beim Journalismus genau darum, die kritischen Fragen zu stellen und entweder hat einer darauf gute Antworten und da zeigt sich alles in Ordnung. Dann ist es wunderbar, dann hat er auch kein Problem. Oder einer hat keine Antworten oder gibt die falschen Antworten. Dann hat er ein Problem und zwar zu Recht. Wenn die Medien, wenn Journalismus überhaupt eine wirklich ernst zu nehmen, der für eine Gesellschaft fast existenzielle Funktion hat, dann ist es genau dieses Recht zu haben, solche Fragen zu stellen, solche Recherchen anzustellen. Das, finde ich, hat die Berichterstattung in der Causa Wulff sehr gut bewiesen. Dass es dann diesen breiten Konsens gab zwischen sehr vielen Zeitungen, Zeitschriften, Webseiten, die normalerweise schon fast ritualhaft immer anderer Meinung sind. Also wenn der das schreibt, schreiben wir das. Und in diesem Fall fanden sie alles das Gleiche. Das spricht für mich noch nicht notwendigerweise dafür, dass das eine groß angelegte Verschwörung der Medienmacht in Deutschland war. Sondern könnte ja auch einfach heißen, der Mann hat wirklich was falsch gemacht.
Nun waren ja viele der Sachen, die gegen den Wohl sprachen, eigentlich frühere Sachen aus seiner Zeit in Hannover. Und es gab ja so Anfeindungen, dass es eine Kampagne der BILD-Zeitung sei und dass sie da in ihr Kompromatarchiv gegriffen haben.
Also bei der BILD-Zeitung wird ja gerne jedes Thema, das in mehr als zwei Artikeln behandelt wird, als Kampagne bezeichnet. Und ich muss sagen, wenn es eine Kampagne ist, sich als einzige Zeitung in Deutschland nicht abschrecken zu lassen von den wirklich unter eklatanten, wahrheitswidrigen Behauptungen zustande gekommenen Abwimmelungsversuchen der Presseberater und Pressestellen des Bundespräsidenten, was die Umstände seines Hauskaufs und seiner Hausfinanzierung betrifft. Wenn also die BILD-Zeitung die einzige Zeitung war, die sich davon nicht hat abschrecken lassen, weiter recherchiert hat, eine Klage genutzt hat, um Auskunft zu erhalten, die Erkenntnisse als einzige Zeitung verknüpft hat, mit einer Aussage in Niedersachsen, dann ist das für mich eine journalistische Glanzleistung. Das ist investigativer Journalismus at its best, der obendrein in diesem Fall auch noch äußerst vorsichtig vorgetragen wurde. Der erste Artikel hieß, die Überschrift sagte wohl vor dem niedersächsischen Landtag, die Unwahrheit, fragezeichen, sinngemäß. Also noch mit Fragezeichen, sehr vorsichtig. Also das ist für mich investigativer Journalismus, ohne wirklich keine Kampagne.
Na Kampagne, also im früheren Interview haben sie immer gesagt, Kampagne sei eigentlich ein positives Wort und sie sehen es gar nicht als schlecht.
Weiß ich nicht, ob ich das so gesagt hab. Agenda ist ein Legativ. Nee, das glaube ich, es kommt drauf an, wie sie eine Kampagne definieren. Wenn eine Kampagne heißt, hartnäckig dranbleiben, ist eine Kampagne was Hervorragendes und bester Journalismus. Wenn eine Kampagne bedeutet, ich hab nix in der Hand, aber blaß die Backen auf und mach große Vorwürfe, dann muss ich sagen, ist eine Kampagne furchtbar und da Kampagne wörtlich übersetzt Felszug heißt und ich immer gegen Felszüge bin, bin ich auch kein Freund von Kampagnen. Nicht in dem Sinne.
Sie sprachen ja vorhin die Grundsätze des Verlages an. Unter anderem die transatlantische Freundschaft, der Zusammenhalt von Europa und die Freundschaft zu Israel. Es sind ja mittlerweile alles drei Themen geworden, wo es durchaus Grund gibt, eben nicht zur blinder Solidarität zu greifen. Fangen wir mal mit der Frage Israel an. Wie definiert sich das denn entlang dieser Grundsätze, eben durchaus Kritik am Vorgehen der israelischen Regierung üben zu können? Oder eben nicht? Weil gerade was die Siedlungspolitik angeht, zum Beispiel, ist es ja durchaus so, dass es da schon ziemlich schwer fällt, irgendwie bedingungslose Solidarität zu üben. Die aber, also die Kritik ist ja in den Blättern Ihres Hauses in der Regel immer etwas eher gedämpft.
Weiß ich nicht. Also ich persönlich halte die Siedlungspolitik Israels für falsch und habe das auch in Gegenwart des israelischen Außenministers und des deutschen Außenministers vor nicht allzu langer Zeit hier in Berlin bei einer Rede gesagt, ihm ins Gesicht. Ich lese auch in unserer Zeitung durchaus immer wieder Kritik an der israelischen Siedlungspolitik und kann eine kritikfreie Zone für Israel und bei diesem Beispiel jetzt zu bleiben überhaupt nicht erkennen. Wenn aber dann Leute sagen, Nahrungsmittel aus Israel sollten gekennzeichnet werden oder am besten gleichpokettiert werden nach dem Motto kauft nicht bei den Juden, dann finde ich, ist das schon ein ganz starkes Stück, wenn man das im Kontext eben auch zu diktatorischen Systemen sieht, wo offenbar keiner Nahrungsmittel kennzeichnen will. Und da finde ich es dann wichtig, dass das auch in unserem Haus vielleicht so ein allgemeiner anti-israelischer Zeitgeist nicht wiederholt wird und eine andere Position vertreten wird. Aber nochmal, ich glaube, es ist dann immer wichtig, einfach zu sagen, wir legen mal die Zeitung nebeneinander, wir gucken uns mal die Artikel an. Und wenn wir dann das Gefühl haben, das hat so wirklich so einen ganz einhelligen Ton, dann wird es mir auch immer unangenehm. Und ich glaube, dass das auch bei den von Ihnen angesprochenen Themen nicht gilt, wenn gleich eines schon richtig ist. In der Frage der Verhinderung jeder Form von neuem Antisemitismus ist dieses Haus sicherlich grundsätzlicher und entschlossener als bei jedem anderen Thema. Und ich glaube, dass wir auch als Haus, das ein Massenmedium wie die BILD-Zeitung und bild.de verlegt, die über zehn Millionen Uniks erreichen, eine besondere Verantwortung hat. Und da geht es wirklich auch um Zwischentöne. Wenn eine solche Marke latent antisemitische Töne zulassen würde und bedienen würde, würden wir hier in Deutschland eine ganz andere Stimmung haben. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass das schon ein Punkt ist, bei dem es in unserem Haus sicherlich eine ganz besondere Sensibilität gibt. Während sie beim Thema Europapolitik oder Bewertung der amerikanischen Regierungspolitik oder anderen Fragen zur Marktwirtschaft so ein breites Spektrum haben, dass wirklich nach meiner Einschätzung nur wirklich alles möglich ist.
Also was mich als Außenstehenden immer interessiert ist, ist das sowas wie das Grundgesetz? Die ersten 20 Artikel, die nie mehr angefasst werden können? Oder könnte irgendwann der Vorstand sagen, ja, das mit der Eurozone haben wir uns nochmal überlegt, das machen wir jetzt anders?
Ich glaube letztes, das ist auch schon mehrfach angepasst worden. Also zum Beispiel die erste Präambel war ursprünglich von Axel Springer 1967 nur der Herstellung der deutschen Einheit gewidmet. War natürlich damals politisch völlig inkorrekt. Also wer in 60er Jahren sagte, die deutsche Einheit muss irgendwann möglich sein, er hat immer gesagt von der friedlichen Einheit in Freiheit. Also hat diese beiden Begriffe immer mitgenommen. Also er hat immer gesagt, es muss friedlich sein. Also nichts irgendwie territorial gewinnen durch Militärisches oder so. Und zweitens, es muss freiheitlich sein. Und ist dafür natürlich als Brandenburger Tor besportet worden. Und die Leute sagten, wer noch die deutsche Einheit für möglich hält, ist ein Reaktionär. Ich habe das selbst an der Frankfurter Uni noch erlebt. Die deutsche Frage galt als beantwortet und man durfte sie auch nicht widerstellen. Er hat damit Recht gehabt. Die deutsche Einheit kam in Freiheit und Frieden zustande. Er hat es leider nicht mehr erlebt. Heute ist es common sense. Jeder sagt es doch gut, dass das Land wieder zusammen ist. Und zu einem neuen Nationalismus oder Faschismus hat es bisher erkennbar nicht geführt. Heute versteht man die Aufregung von damals gar nicht mehr. Als das dann eintrat, machte diese Präambel natürlich keinen Sinn. Man hat sie angepasst und hat eben gesagt, es geht um die deutsche Einheit, also sie weiter zu erhalten und zu vertiefen und eben um die Einigungsbemögen der europäischen Völker, sprich um die europäische Einheit. Und ein noch eklatanteres Beispiel ist, dass es die fünfte Präambel, die sich mit der Solidarität in der freiheitlichen Wertegemeinschaft mit Amerika definiert, dass die überhaupt erst 2001, nämlich nach 9-11, um genau zu sein am 13. als zusätzliche fünfte Präambel auf unsere Initiative vom Aufsichtsrat verabschiedet, überhaupt erst eingeführt worden ist.
Sie als Transatlantiker, schmerzt sie das, wenn sie mitkriegen, wie in Amerika Dinge nicht gut laufen?
Ja.
Also ist das immer noch ein Vorbild für Sie?
Wissen Sie, also meine Mutter hat mir gesagt, die größte Form der Liebe ist Kritik. Und wenn ihnen etwas wichtig ist, wenn sie ein Land, das in seiner, sagen wir mal, entschiedenen Freiheitlichkeit und nicht-feudalen Demokratie-Idee schon für viele Dinge Vorbild ist und ganz tolle Sachen einfach erreicht hat und prägend ist, ich meine, wenn wir über die digitale Welt reden, die hätten wir wohl ohne Amerika nicht, dann schmerzt es sie besonders, wenn sie das Gefühl haben, da laufen Sachen schief. Und da gibt es natürlich ganz viele Sachen, mit denen ich mich aktuell, aber auch so historisch, überhaupt nicht identifizieren kann und die ich völlig falsch finde. Das fängt bei so ernsten Themen wie der Todesstrafe an, die ich einer Demokratie für unwürdig halte und nicht verstehen kann, warum das überhaupt denkbar ist, dass so eine glaubwürdige Demokratie wie Amerika die Todesstrafe hat. Und es hört bei Banalitäten auf, wie die Tatsache ist, die Klimaanlagen in Amerika immer zu kalt eingestellt sind.
Also der dritte Grundsatz, über den wir diskutieren, nämlich die europäische Einheit, ist ja durchaus eine Sache, die nun ja keine Selbstverständlichkeit mehr zu sein scheint. Also es gibt ja, gerade haben wir so ein bisschen so eine Situation, die da auch zu herauslaufen scheint. Zum einen entweder wir bauen einen europäischen Superstaat, um irgendwie die Banken-Bailouts irgendwie weiter zu finanzieren, der irgendwie demokratisch nur so mäßig legitimiert wird. Oder wir fallen zurück in, sagen wir mal, eine nationalstaatliche Kleinstaaterei. Also die große Frage dabei ist ja so ein bisschen unter anderem eben auch, wie positioniert sich die öffentliche Meinung. Wo ihr Haus natürlich ja durchaus einen großen Einfluss darauf hat. Und ich meine, wenn ich mir jetzt so angucke, was die Pläne so sind, irgendwie werden regiert von einem Komitee der Finanzminister. So viel Macht haben wir eigentlich gar nicht da rein getan in die letzten Wahlen. Also sozusagen diese immer weitere Delegation von Macht führt ja eben dann durchaus schon zum Demokratiedefizit. Und nehmen wir mal an, irgendwie Herr Schäuble setzt sich durch und es gibt halt eben eine Volksabstimmung. Wie würde die Positionierung Ihres Hauses ablaufen?
Also ich fürchte, ich muss Ihnen da eine Antwort geben, die Sie nicht befriedigen kann, denn ich habe keine. Es ist ja vielleicht auch so eine Erscheinung der Politik und der Mediengesellschaft, dass jeder immer auf alles eine Antwort haben muss. Ich muss sagen, bei dieser so großen Schicksalsfrage habe ich eine gewisse demütige Sprachlosigkeit. Ich habe dafür keine Antwort. Ich habe kein Rezept. Ich finde es wahnsinnig kompliziert. Ich beneide keinen Politiker, der die Verantwortung hat, in so einer schicksalshaften Frage jetzt wirklich Entscheidungen zu treffen. Ich weiß, dass Entscheidungen getroffen werden müssen, weil Unentschiedenheit, Unklarheit ist sozusagen die schlechteste aller Optionen. Übrigens ganz besonders an den Kapitalmärkten. Die hassen nicht so sehr wie Unentschiedenheit und Ambivalenz und Unklarheit. Aber es ist eben in der Tat fürchterlich schwer, hier jetzt die richtige Entscheidung zu treffen. Und es scheint doch so, dass beide Extreme falsch sind. Zu sagen Solidarität heißt, es wird alles so lang umverteilt, bis keiner mehr was hat, führt zu einer europäischen DDR und wird einfach nicht funktionieren, wird zur Verarmung Europas führen. Und umgekehrt zu sagen, tja, ihr habt es halt nicht geschafft, Pech gehabt, dann machen wir eben alleine weiter, wird zu massiven Verwerfungen führen, möglicherweise zu einem Scheitern des Euro und der europäischen Idee und im Übrigen wahrscheinlich auch zu erheblichen wirtschaftlichen Verwerfungen in Deutschland. Denn wenn wir mit einer D-Mark arbeiten und die dermaßen aufwertet, dass keiner mehr deutsche Produkte kauft, dann wünsche ich dem Exportweltmeister Deutschland viel Spaß beim Exportieren. Da wird hier die Arbeitslosigkeit in die Höhe schnellen und es wird eine sehr unruhige Situation in der Gesellschaft geben. Also das ist ein hochgradig besorgniserregendes Thema. Und ich glaube, dass man wird versuchen müssen, in einem sinnvollen Kompromiss ein Prinzip hochzuhalten. Das bedeutet, dass in einer Marktwirtschaft es nicht so sein darf, dass die Gewinne privatisiert sind und die Verluste verstaatlicht.
Was aber gerade der Fall ist. Also ich meine, gerade ist es ja so, dass ein Großteil der angewerften Schulden kommt hier eben aus den Banken-Bailouts, in denen ja genau die Verluste verstaatlicht werden. Und welche, welche, also ich meine, am Ende ist es ja ein dramatisches Demokratiedefizit, weil ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass irgendwie die Leute, also die Wähler, eine Regierung gewählt haben, die sowas beschließt, in dem Willen, dass sie irgendwie an Lister-Tuberde später mit irgendwie einer Billion Euro mehr Schulden dastehen, die am Ende irgendwie in den Taschen von den Banken gelandet sind.
Gut, aber das kann ja eh niemand zurückzahlen. Ich denke, insofern ist das so eine Unrealsache. Naja, ich glaube, das ist der Grund, warum die Bevölkerung sich nicht so betroffen fühlt, weil das so unreale Zahlen sind, dass niemand glaubt, er persönlich wird irgendwann belangt werden.
Das ist richtig. Die Zahlen sind so groß, dass sie entrücken. Sie sind nicht mehr greifbar. Sie sind für normalen Menschen überhaupt nicht mehr verständlich. Sie sind dadurch auch gar nicht mehr bedrohlich. Und das ist gefährlich. Die Zahl verliert eigentlich ihre Aussagekraft. Aber wissen Sie, es ist so furchtbar einfach, hinterher schlauer zu sein. Ich meine, klar, aus heutiger Sicht muss man sagen, wie konnte man eine europäische Einheitswährung schaffen, ohne eine gewisse Idee der politischen Union definiert und umgesetzt zu haben? Natürlich war die Reihenfolge falsch. Man hätte erst die politische Union haben müssen und dann die gemeinsame Währung. Vermutlich hätte man aber ohne die gemeinsame Währung nie die politische Union bekommen. Und deswegen hat damals Kohl einfach gesagt, Augen zu und durch und hat diesen Euro durchgepaugt. Und jetzt vielleicht, um der ganzen Sache noch ein Hauch optimistische Denkweise zu vermitteln, möglicherweise ist ja der alte Satz, dass in jeder Krise eine Chance liegt, auch diesmal wahr. Wenn die Krise nicht zur Totalkatastrophe führt, zur Apokalypse des Euro, dann kann sie ja vielleicht dazu führen, dass sie zumindest die Notwendigkeit einer politischen Union erkennbar macht und dann auch die Umsetzung einer politischen Union beschleunigt. Also das wäre zumindest der positivste Ausgang, dass die Sache finanzarchitektonisch noch stabil gehalten werden kann und man gleichzeitig über eine politische Union definiert, was geht und was nicht, und Spielregeln definiert, die nicht in Eurosozialismus führen, aber die eben auch nicht in eine europäische Entsolidarisierung führen, nach dem Motto, der Stärkere setzt sich immer durch.
Wir haben ja, wenn wir uns umgucken in Europa, im Zuge der Krise und auch schon vorher, einen Erstarken von nationalistischen Resultaten geladener Bewegung. Im Nachbarland Niederlande haben wir eine sehr stark anti-muslimische Bewegung von Herrn Wilders, die zwar sehr israelfreundlich ist und sehr stark prosemitisch positioniert, aber auf der anderen Seite halt irgendwie einen offenen Muslim-Hass propagiert.
Ungarn haben sie auch eine Nationalisierung.
Ungarn haben die Fallkreuzler wieder auf Verstehung. Sie haben in Griechenland diese Golden Dawn-Leute. Es gab ja mal diesen kerzerischen Satz, es wird in Deutschland nie eine rechtspopulistische Partei geben, rechts der BILD-Zeitung. Wie sehen Sie diese Entwicklung?
Mit allergrößter Sorge, weil das, was Sie beschreiben, das ist das wirklich größte Problem. Das ist viel größer als alle finanzmathematischen Probleme und negativen wirtschaftlichen Entwicklungen, die vielleicht die Folge sein können. Der Nationalismus hat der Welt nur Unglück gebracht. Und deswegen bleibt die europäische Idee von allen politischen Ideen der letzten 100 Jahre oder vielleicht der letzten Jahrhunderte die wichtigste, wertvollste, schützenswerteste Idee. Die Renationalisierung in Europa wäre ein fatales Unglück. Ich glaube, dass das Elend über die Menschen bringt, wirtschaftliches Elend und auch wirklich Unfrieden und Gewalt und Terrorismus und Krieg. Deswegen muss alles getan werden, das zu verhindern. Man kann das in so vielen Beispielen in der Geschichte nachlesen, wo diese nationalistischen Entwicklungen eben Vorboten von großem Unglück waren. Und deswegen ist es aber zugleich auch so schwer, jetzt die richtige Antwort zu finden, weil ist sozusagen derjenige, der um jeden Preis die europäische Solidarität im Sinne der Maximal-Umverteilung propagiert. Ist das wirklich der echte und wertvolle Freund Europas? Oder ist das vielleicht genau der Weg, der dann eben diesen Nationalismus als Gegenreaktion, wir lassen uns doch von denen nicht unser Geld aus der Tasche ziehen, befördert? Und das finde ich ist so wahnsinnig schwer, hier den richtigen Weg zu finden. Also manchmal sind die größten Freunde einer Idee in Wahrheit ihre schlimmsten Feinde. Und ich glaube, dass man hier einfach so einen nüchternen, fairen Pragmatismus braucht, um eben diese Renationalisierung zu verhindern. Das aber finde ich muss das oberste Ziel sein. Also wenn Deutschland glaubt, dass sie mit einem nationalen Sonderweg wieder was erreichen können, dann kann ich nur sagen, viel Vergnügen. Das geht sicher schief.
Wir haben mit dem Herrn Schommacher eben einen schönen Gedanken geäußert, den ich hier auch nochmal ansprechen möchte. Er meinte, dadurch, dass die Lage so verfahren wirkt, ist das nicht ein Gefängnis, sondern eine Freiheit. Man kann sagen, wenn die ganze finanzielle Sache eh unlösbar aussieht, dann können wir uns auf den humanistischen Teil beschränken und sagen, was wollen wir denn eigentlich? Wenn wir sagen können, diesen ganzen finanzmathematischen Blah, das versteht keiner und das kriegen wir eh nicht kurzfristig hin. Also ist jetzt die große Freiheit da, der Moment, um da mal zu sagen, was wir eigentlich haben wollen.
Wenn ich den Gedanken richtig verstehe, liegt er ziemlich nah an dem, was ich vorhin meinte, als ich gesagt habe, auch in dieser Krise kann es Chancen sein. Wir können, weil die materielle Dimension so verfahren, die intellektuelle Dimension mit größerer Freiheit definieren und daraus etwas ziehen, was uns langfristig weiterbringt. Das wäre der bestmögliche Fall. Ich hoffe, dass wir diese Freiheiten nutzen und dass das Demokraten tun, dass das weltoffene Menschen tun und dass jetzt wirklich etwas definiert wird, was ist diesen Weg zu mehr Europa, zu mehr Weltoffenheit, zu mehr Internationalität und damit natürlich auch zu mehr Vorteil durch diese Internationalität für jeden Einzelnen. Und damit meine ich den Vorteil, dass man überall die Jeans in der gleichen Währung kaufen kann, genauso wie die große Frage des volkswirtschaftlichen, der volkswirtschaftlichen Gesundheit der deutschen Gesellschaft. Das alles jetzt wirklich zu sichern und es nicht zuzulassen, dass diese Entwicklung, diese Fehlentwicklung dazu führt, dass sozusagen die falschen Dämagogen einfache Lösungen und in sich geschlossene Weltbilder präsentieren, die Ressentiment-Vorurteil, Nationalismus, Isolation und am Ende dann Hass und Gewalt bewirken.
Sie sind ja ein sehr bekennender Freund des Kapitalismus. Wenn man sich aber jetzt mal die Ursachen der Krise anguckt, dann haben wir da ganz klar, sagen wir mal, Regulierungsmängel. Also ganz klar die...
Wissen Sie was, wir haben keine Regulierungsmängel, sondern wir haben Anstandsmängel. Wir haben Selbstregulierungsmängel. Die Krise des Kapitalismus ist durch ein Missverständnis oder durch einen Missbrauch des Kapitalismus zustande gekommen.
Das klingt jetzt aber so ein bisschen so wie irgendwie die Argumentation, dass die DDR ja eigentlich auch ein gutes System war, sie war nur falsch implementiert.
Nee, das glaube ich nicht. Also pass auf, da will ich es Ihnen schon sehr viel konkreter sagen. Also ich sehe zwei Hauptursachen, die diese Bewegung in Gang gesetzt haben. Zum einen, ich kann es Ihnen nicht ersparen, aber auch die Politik hat gerade durch Regulierung hier eine ganz wesentliche Voraussetzung geschaffen. Das war die amerikanische Regierung und zwar mehrere, die von Clinton und die weitergeführt auch von Bush, die nach der Idee, jeder Amerikaner muss ein Hausbesitzer sein, zu irrationalen Rahmenbedingungen, regulierten Rahmenbedingungen geführt hat, die es jedem ermöglicht haben, egal ob er sich es leisten konnte oder nicht, so viel Schulden aufzunehmen, non recourse, also ohne Verantwortung, um sich ein Haus zu kaufen, dass er sich eigentlich nicht leisten kann. So entstand die Immobilienblase, deswegen ist das Ding irgendwann kollabiert und das war ein ganz wesentlicher Ursprung der Finanzkrise. Das ist das eine und das war erst mal ein Regulierungsversagen und ein Politikversagen. Die zweite Ursache ist der Missbrauch marktwirtschaftlicher Freiheiten durch gierige Vertreter einer Finanzindustrie, die vorgetäuscht hat, noch den Regeln der Marktwirtschaft zu dienen, die aber im Grunde, sagen wir mal, reine Raubrittermodelle bedient hat. Das war ein Exzess marktwirtschaftlicher Freiheit, das war ein Missbrauch der Freiheit, das war teilweise halbkriminelles, teilweise vollständig kriminelles Verhalten, Medoff und andere. Und dadurch ist, sagen wir mal, eine ganze Industrie, der gesamte Bankensektor, die gesamte Investment-Private-Equity-Branche in Dauerverruf geraten. Sicher zu Unrecht, weil die Mehrheit da immer noch ordentliche Sachen macht. Aber es waren zu viele, und das muss man wirklich sagen, auch nicht nur Einzelfälle, es waren zu viele, die dieses System in diesem Sinne gekidnappt haben und es dadurch massiv beschädigt vielleicht sogar zerstört haben. Das ist jetzt nicht eine Verklärung, dass ich das sage. Übrigens mit der DDR, den Vergleich finde ich irgendwie unangebracht.
Wenn wir mal an die Ursachen gucken, dann ist eine der Ursachen durchaus eben, dass die Regulierung stattfand. Dass Retail-Banken plötzlich auch Investment-Banken sein konnten. Und dass am Ende die Leute, die regulieren sollten, die in den Finanzministerien saßen, aus der Industrie kamen. Und die halt irgendwie die Dinge getan haben, die ihre alten Buddies gerne wollten, um ihre Rob-Ritter-Modelle durchzuziehen. Und da wollte ich schon sagen, dass es klar ist, dass das Pegel, das Pendel wieder in die andere Richtung schwingen wird. Die Frage ist eben nur, wie sollte eine sinnvolle Regulierung aussehen? Wie ist das sinnvolle Verhältnis zwischen Staat und Freiheit des Marktes? Das muss ja offensichtlich neu verhandelt werden.
Also mir hat neulich ein amerikanischer Bekannter erzählt, dass er an einem Abendessen teilnahm, in dem der amerikanische Präsident sich über die aktuelle Krise bei JP Morgan kundig machte. Und dann zu der Conclusio kam, wenn der Vorstandsvorsitzende einer der größten und erfolgreichsten Banken der Welt es nicht mal schafft, solches Systemversagen in seinem Haus zu verhindern, dann kann doch die eindeutige Konsequenz für die Politik nur sein. Dann müssen wir durch eine massive Regulierung diese aus der Kontrolle geratenen, nicht mehr kontrollierbaren Systeme verändern. Das ist erstmal sehr leicht nachvollziehbar. Ein weiteres Beispiel, wodurch ein selbst verursachtes Fehlverhalten vielleicht ein ganzes System in Schieflage gebracht wird. Ich glaube nur, dass dieser Weg oder diese Konsequenz am Ende falsch wäre. Weil wenn wir glauben, dass die Politik, dass der Regulierer Bankgeschäfte besser betreibt und besser kontrolliert als privatwirtschaftliche Mechanismen und Aktionäre, dann möchte ich einfach nur auf die Geschichte der großen Bankskandale, insbesondere in Deutschland verweisen. Das waren im Wesentlichen Landesbanken, die von Politikern beaufsichtigt und von Politikern reguliert wurden. Und die haben die größte Milliardenverbrennung zumindest in Deutschland bewirkt. Und wie gesagt auch auf das Beispiel Immobilienblase in Amerika, die ebenfalls politisch induziert ist. Also ich glaube dieses Hin- und Herschieben zwischen Privatwirtschaft und Politik und dieser Machtkampf, jetzt müssen wir es mal den Kapitalistenschwein wegnehmen und wir nehmen es mal als Staatswieder fest in die Hand, halte ich für ziemlich naiv und auch in der Konsequenz für gefährlich. Deswegen meine konkrete Antwort auf Ihre Frage, wie könnte es denn gehen, wenn das nicht der Weg ist? Und ich sehe da eigentlich nur eine, wenn man so will, letzte Chance, von der ich auch nicht weiß, ob sie funktioniert. Das wäre aber eine freiwillige Selbstregulierung, eine freiwillige Selbstbeschränkung, eine freiwillige Neuorientierung der marktwirtschaftlichen Player. Und da habe ich einen ganz altmodischen Begriff parat. Und das ist der Begriff des ehrbaren Kaufmanns. Der Begriff ist ja Jahrhunderte alt und dem werden verschiedene Eigenschaften zugewiesen. Und dazu gehört eben, dass es eine gesamtgesellschaftliche Verantwortung gibt, desjenigen, der sich in einem marktwirtschaftlichen Kontext bewegt, dass es Gebote der Fairness, der Verlässlichkeit, der Gerechtigkeit gibt, die der Einzelne nicht verletzen darf, dass es auch eine Kategorie von Anstand und Glaubwürdigkeit gibt. Das klingt jetzt alles sehr altmodisch. Das klingt vielleicht auch ein bisschen abstrakt und vage angesichts von Milliarden- und Billionsummen, die irgendwie abhandengekommen sind. Ich glaube aber, dass nur eine Selbstbesinnung der wirtschaftlichen Akteure selbst Grenzen zu definieren und einfach zu sagen, bestimmte Sachen gehören sich nicht und die machen wir nicht und bestimmte Produkte und Derivate bieten wir einfach nicht an, weil klar ist, dass das irgendwie eine Art von Kettenbrief-Geschäftsmodell ist, das nicht seriös ist. Nur durch eine solche Verhaltensänderung der kapitalistischen Akteure kann größeres Unheil verhindert werden. Ob die eintritt, ob es diese Erkenntnis gibt oder ob man weiter versucht, in den Regulierungslücken quasi kriminelle Geschäftsmodelle zu betreiben, das ist eine offene Frage. Ich kann nur sagen, diese Finanzkrise ist mit Sicherheit der letzte Warnschuss für die Akteure, die sich im marktwirtschaftlichen Geschehen nicht an die Regeln halten und nicht an die wichtigsten Regeln halten. Und die heißt Anstand und gesunder Menschenverstand. Was du nicht willst, was man dir tut, das füge auch keinem anderen zu. Ganz so einfach.
Das gibt mir gerade die Gelegenheit zu einer schönen Überleitung zu unserem letzten Thema, was wir ansprechen wollten. Claudius Seidel hat ja der BILD-Zeitung in der FAZ vorgeworfen, dass tatsächlich ein Mangel weder Kampagne noch irgendwas ist, sondern ein Mangel an Anstand und Haltung. Diese Debatte entzündete sich gerade an dieser BILD für alle Geschichte und der assoziierten Werbekampagne. Sie als intellektuell relativ weitgebildeter Mensch. Wie fühlt man sich mit so was wie einer BILD-Zeitung im Haus?
Prachtvoll. Und ich muss auch wirklich sagen, also ganz davon abgesehen, dass es natürlich seit 12 Jahren ein festes Ritual ist, mir in jedem Interview zu versuchen, einen kritischen Satz über die BILD-Zeitung zu entlocken. Angelehnt an das berühmte Springer-Zitat, wenn ich morgens die BILD-Zeitung lese, leide ich wie ein Hund. Dass man ihn damals in der Zeit entlockt hat. Ich bin bisher in diese Falle noch nie getappt. Ich kritisiere die BILD-Zeitung intern. Jetzt wäre eine gute Gelegenheit. Extern tue ich es nicht. Aber ich will Ihnen auch noch ein anderes Argument nennen, warum ich es besonders gerne nicht tue. Weil ich natürlich bei allem, was man zu Recht an jeder Zeitung und so auch an der BILD-Zeitung kritisieren kann, diese fast ritualhafte Bildpolemik, ehrlich gesagt, ein bisschen billig finde und intellektuell mittlerweile fast beleidigend. Ich meine, der Skandal der BILD-Zeitung ist doch nicht, dass sie Boulevard ist. Sie ist eine Boulevard-Zeitung. Eine Boulevard-Zeitung lebt davon, dass sie sich möglichst breiten Leserschichten öffnet. Im Jahr 1900 haben zehn Prozent der Deutschen eine Zeitung gelesen. Im Jahr 2000 waren es 73 Prozent und Sie können sicher sein, ein Großteil davon ist durch Produkte wie die BILD-Zeitung, vor allen Dingen durch die BILD-Zeitung selbst überhaupt zum Lesen gekommen. Wenn man das so macht, dann muss man das natürlich anders machen als die Neuzüricher Zeitung oder die Welt oder die FAZ. Das heißt, man muss es laut machen, mit großen Überschriften machen. Man muss es in einer knappen Form machen. Man muss es sehr verständlich tun. Das heißt, man muss vor allen Dingen verkürzen, emotionalisieren, personalisieren. Das sind eigentlich die drei wesentlichen Ingredienzen des Boulevard-Journalismus. Das ist noch nicht per se schlecht. Es gibt ja diesen Bildspruch, wer etwas zu sagen hat, macht keine langen Sätze. Und manchmal ist es ganz gut, wenn man Dinge mal wirklich auf ihren Kern einkocht, dann sieht man nämlich, ob da noch Substanz bleibt oder ob der Suppenwürfel ganz verdampft. Aber es ist doch jedenfalls klar, dass Boulevard Boulevard ist. Und das zu kritisieren, finde ich irgendwie einen banalen Vorwurf, was ich viel interessanter finde. Nur den Satz, naja oft doch, weil sie einfach sagen, es ist so geschmacklos, es ist so verkürzt, es ist so vereinfacht und so weiter. Und natürlich ist es eine große Überschrift in so einer Handbreite, die ist natürlich nicht so fein zisilliert, wie eine schöne Serifenüberschrift in der neuen Züricher Zeitung. Aber nochmal, ich finde doch medienkritisch den viel interessanteren Ansatz, die Boulevardisierung der sogenannten Qualitätsmedien zu kritisieren. Das ist doch ein Problem. Warum kritisiert keiner die Titel großer Qualitätszeitschriften, die sich mit Tanja Gesell und ihren Kunstbusen beschäftigen? Da sind fünf Seiten in einer sehr angesehenen deutschen Qualitätszeitschrift drüber geschrieben worden. Warum regt sich keiner auf, dass eine führende deutsche Nachrichtenagentur als Eilmeldung verbreitet, dass das Kind von Franz Beckenbauer zum ersten Mal heute mit einer Nanny alleine zu Hause ist? Also ich meine, das sind doch medienkritisch eigentlich die viel interessanteren Themen, die Boulevardisierung der sogenannten Qualitätsmedien.
Also das kann ich mir jetzt nicht vorwerfen. Ich sag immer, das ist Ihr malige Nachrichtsmagazin, wenn ich vom Spiegel rede.
Na gut, aber der wichtigere Teil dabei ist ja, also die inhaltliche Kritik neben eine Boulevardzeitung ist eine Boulevardzeitung. Das kann uns nicht so aufregen, wir sind auch immer alternativlos ein Boulevard-Podcast, damit wir uns an bestimmte Standards nicht halten müssen. Und wir haben halt einfach den, also Boulevard ist geschenkt. Interessanter ist aber tatsächlich ja eben die Frage, dass ja gehäuft gerade in der BILD-Zeitung Sachen auftreten, wo falsche Geschichten groß rausgebracht werden, wo Leute hinterher leiden und es dann doch sehr hart ist, für die, sag mal, eine richtige Stellung zu erzielen.
Also das ist eine Aussage, die muss ich jetzt wirklich vehement bestreiten. Dass in der BILD-Zeitung Fehler passieren und Fehlberichterstattungen, das ist richtig, dass es mehr passiert als in anderen Zeitungen, halte ich sogar für ausgesprochen falsch. Ich glaube, dass keine Zeitung in Deutschland so genau und so vorsichtig und präzise recherchiert wie die BILD-Zeitung, weil nämlich jeder Fehler, der in der BILD-Zeitung gemacht wird, überproportionales Echo findet und wahnsinnig bemerkt wird. Und deswegen sind die besonders vorsichtig. Wir kennen die Beispiele, Bolzenschneider vor zehn Jahren und so weiter. Oder jetzt gerade wieder die Sache mit dem falschen Foto, wofür sich BILD sofort entschuldigt hat. Und das ist ein überhaupt nicht zu beschönigender, echter, handwerklicher Fehler. Das passiert, aber sobald BILD was passiert, ist es eine Riesen-Story. Wenn das in der Süddeutschen oder in der FAZ oder im Hamburger Abendblatt oder irgendwo anders passiert oder in der AD oder im ZDF, da sagt man, na ja, das ist ja passiert halt mal. Und da, finde ich, wird irgendwie auch mit zweierlei Maß gemessen. Es ist halt immer, alles, was BILD macht, fällt besonders auf. Und BILD macht bestimmte Sachen falsch. Und dann sind sie auch sehr wirkungsstark, wenn irgendwo ein Persönlichkeitsrecht in der BILD-Zeitung verletzt wird, wenn ein Faktum falsch zitiert wird oder falsch dargestellt wird. Dann hat das besondere Wirkung. Und wenn BILD wehtut, dann tut BILD eben auch besonders weh. Aber ich muss einfach sagen, BILD tut auch sehr viel wirklich Gutes. Und auch beim Gutes tun ist BILD halt stärker als andere, wenn sie mal gucken, was mit Herz für Kinder jedes Jahr an zweistelligen Millionenbeträgen zusammengetragen wird. Wenn sie gucken, was das Engagement auch der BILD-Zeitung wirklich für Kunst und Kultur bewirkt.
Aber meinen Sie nicht, dass es tatsächlich eben durch den Boulevard-Anspruch eher nicht eher ein kulturelles Problem ist? Also dass halt einfach der sozusagen der Wille bissig zu sein, der natürlich mit dem Willen unterhaltsam zu sein einhergeht. Meine gut, was ich bei Ihnen höre, ist, dass Sie schon sagen, dass Sie davon ausgehen, dass die Zeitung dadurch, dass sie eine größere Keule ist, eine große Verantwortung hat. Ja, also dass sie halt einfach den Versuch unternimmt. Aber trotzdem halt ja relativ frequent passiert, dass halt also Sachen, also mal BILD-Blog lesen zum Beispiel, die ja doch eigentlich fast in jeder Ausgabe Sachen finden, die halt...
Wir machen mal ein neuer Züricher-Blog oder ein süddeutscher-Blog. Machen sie mal, ich bin für nochmal...
Machen sie mal süddeutsche, die haben ja eh gerade...
Dass quantitativ die Fehlerzahl höher ist. Also ich sag's einfach noch mal ganz klar, BILD macht Fehler, aber BILD macht Fehler nicht absichtlich. BILD erfindet keine Geschichten, BILD fälscht keine Fakten, sondern versucht wirklich wahrheitsgemäß zu berichten, aber natürlich die Dinge zuzuspitzen, sie zu emotionalisieren und sie sozusagen am breiteren Publikum verständlich zu machen. Und ich würde mir einfach etwas mehr Entspanntheit wünschen. Wir müssen nicht sagen, die BILD-Zeitung macht alles richtig. Das wäre naiv und dumm und auch peinlich. Aber umgekehrt ist sozusagen dieser automatische Reflex, dass sich alle von der Epoche des guten Geschmacks erraplehen und sagen, guck mal, was diese Proleten auf dem Boulevarder wieder für geschmacklose Sachen gemacht haben, finde ich eben als medenkritische Haltung unglaublich billig und fanspannender, wenn wir uns auch mal mit den Verfehlungen und den Boulevardisierungstendenzen der Qualitätsmedien auseinandersetzen würden, weil wenn es nämlich eine BILD-Zeitung gibt, aber da drum rum, ganz viele Medien, die in sehr differenzierter Weise nach dem Warum und nach dem Wie und nach den Zwischentönen und den Hintergründen fragen, dann haben wir eine wunderbar ausgewogene Medienvielfalt. Wenn aber irgendwann alle so aussehen wie die BILD-Zeitung, dann wird es problematisch.
Ärgert sie das eigentlich, dass die Welt weniger Leser hat als die BILD?
Ich würde mir wünschen, dass die Welt mindestens so viel Leser hat wie die BILD-Zeitung, aber es liegt in der Natur der Sache, dass sie es nicht haben kann, weil die Welt ist eine Zeitung, die sich letztlich an ein sehr elitäres Publikum wendet. Und das tut die BILD-Zeitung nicht. Und das kann man verachten, weil man elitär ist und sagt, wir wollen nur eine Zeitung für Hochgebildete machen. Ich finde es gut, dass es beides gibt.
Ja, dann sind wir am Ende. Sie müssen zum Flieger.
Stimmt.
Dann vielen Dank fürs Gespräch.
Hat mir Spaß gemacht.
Dankeschön. Dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.